hello my friends my beautiful people it
is Friday thank God it's TV I am
thank God
you know
finally man
um joined today by the Beautiful the
lovely the fertile
I don't know that's a weird compliment
right uh eloquine thank you
we love her thank you we love her folks
today's episode episode sponsored by
hexclad and Shopify thank you to our
wonderful sponsors we love love ELO
looks fantastic your hair I love the
hair thank you you you got rid of the
extensions I got rid of it and I'm
loving your natural hair color thank you
I needed to feel free it felt like I was
in prison
basically and um
it was actually when Shredder passed I
felt like I just want to feel like naked
in a way if it makes sense you wanted
that was some way that was when I took
the extensions off I was like I don't
want this on me right now I feel like
clean
so you really feel them when they're in
there oh my God
so uncomfortable I don't I like yours I
don't think you need to do all that okay
you're beautiful player it's thick too
you even need to deal with all that
thank you I just I had this idea of like
going from short to long you know which
was why I did it yeah just wanted to
have like long hair for a minute yeah it
was cool but we're back very
uncomfortable we're so bad
[Applause]
um
today we have so much to talk about in
fact we were um
we were in the laboratory with the title
for about an hour because we had so much
to jam in there you guys we have a
PowerPoint
presentation
I'm excited for that one about uh Joe
Jonas
is he the worst of the Jonas's do we not
like Joe or go to Joe well can we put
the Jonas Brothers on a tier list
Joe Frankie of course being number one
absolutely yes here yeah easy so yeah so
can we do that a tier list of the Jonas
Brothers
we have to learn about the situation but
let's do that I don't know much about
the other two I could give you a rundown
on them okay so let's do a tier list go
to Joe Frankie will be number one
everybody stands frankly absolutely oh
well I'm getting an update the there is
a Israeli Discord up and running
there you go congratulations strong guys
so we've got that we've got uh Logan
Paul versus Dylan Dennis I haven't
talked about this yet but I've been
following it it's pretty interesting
they're set to fight
yeah but um this guy Dylan Dennis who
seems like a real psychopath
has been and by the way I mean he's
doing it to Logan Paul that makes me
feel less bad but then he's doing it to
his fiance he's like terrorizing them so
much so that Logan Paul's fiance is
trying to get a restraining order again
oh my God
and I mean you know you always go well
how much is this is fake this is real
well especially with the ball Brothers
but this guy Dylan the he's saying
yeah is like you wouldn't say right
okay I haven't seen anything we can come
to the conclusion it's wild this guy's
out of control dude this guy Dylan
but it couldn't happen to a worse person
you know couldn't happen I mean he like
he was wearing the I think he bought the
exact
ha
or if it was the hat but he got the same
hat from the suicide forest and he's
been wearing it and
so I'm talking about his scams and
everything like really just going all
the way down
going all the way down on him I really
hate to say this
I know it I know it and so then the
other big one is uh
what gebama
oh yeah gay Obama we've been I've been
so sorry that's huge okay I'm very
excited to hear that's the biggest story
though yeah gay Obama sounds legit yeah
I agree yes I I'm yes handing this so I
can't wait to
well and dick too apparently and crack
and Dick and crack too dick too oh he
said and dick too
how'd you do that it was a group project
between me and Dan but I had an idea I'm
like instead of him saying you had
to say dick for the second Play It Again
dick too I didn't do that did you did
you take rabbit from somewhere else Dick
Cheney Dick Cheney is a thing so of
course Obama has said the word dick a
million times okay so you put the dick
in yeah sounds good thank you yeah it
was it sounds really clean thank you
thank you one more time dick too
it like that so um
I think
um so as I was saying on one piece I was
saying that I have to eat crow today a
little bit really because I was talking
about one piece
um was gonna be awful I said there's
zero oh yes oh yeah right oh I was right
there with you I had on it
and so we watched the whole thing yep
ELO watched the whole damn thing with me
I like it and um
I gotta say especially by the end
of it I thought it was really good
pretty sold huh me too and I walked in
first thing and Ian's sitting there with
a big guy he's like happy he's like
excited to talk about one piece yeah he
is
yep the first time I've ever smiled
I I got into it like I said before the
show I looked up five episodes of the
Netflix show it's like 40 episodes of
the anime so I liked the Lesser time
commitment I can't do a thousand
episodes but I was getting into it okay
well so I'll say this they're each an
hour long so that's like three episodes
so it's like three times eight so it's
like 24 but I'll tell you this if you're
trying to get into one piece I would
actually say watch the first show watch
Netflix instead of season one because
it's condensed it's good it doesn't
leave anything out and it's it's I think
it's pretty true to the to the anime and
it's it's really well done and it's fun
I would I would recommend that over the
first season
yeah someone who's never seen the anime
I I've been enjoying the show I'm
curious now if you want to continue the
anime it basically picks up right where
it left off in season two so it's pretty
cool that's basically what I started
doing now because I I left the Netflix
show feeling like I want more and now I
was ready to get into the anime where
before I always felt like this is a
beast I can't get into it it is yeah but
you know all the characters you go in I
will say the first the first Arc out of
that was pretty long and dull but now
you're getting into the part the better
part yeah
the grand line the grand line baby you
know what it is
[Laughter]
yeah so okay I'm glad you're enjoying it
but there you go I have to apologize to
uh Luffy and the Gang
while we're here talking about culture
Salt Lake City housewife just started
shit's boring
boring I'll tell you what's my problem
we watched the yeah he's in premiere
so Jen Shaw's in jail yeah she's gone
and these women are so full of
themselves like they show up they're all
like in the most designer brand like
these women they're they're they're
they're such fashion slaves in like the
literal sense everything they wear has
like the big branding on it they're just
they're they just think they're too
important now they're literally and
you're just nobodies like you all need
to like
they are they're nobodies they need to
understand that they're Housewives well
it's not fun when they're Housewives
yeah everyone they're nobodies
yeah
you know like they're not as catty
they're more um
they're too important now I feel like
they're like oh I gotta look good on the
show where before they were calling they
were calling each other Shrek
one of the girls there's like a little
bigger bodied like big boned not even
like fat necessarily she's just big
boned and the other ladies were calling
her Shrek bro
that's crazy right yeah and so that's
the show that I want to watch I see yeah
um Lucy goosey here said Heather thinks
she's the exactly Heather's become
so and it's not the one there that's the
one that they were calling Shrek yes
yeah
oh so they were she used to be very
lovable and then she became kind of like
the most hated I feel like well anyway
you know what I mean uh what can you say
I'm still gonna watch it don't get me
wrong all right
anyway so um one thing oh yeah Teddy
fresh drop is out yesterday
quickly here it's all available right
now at teddyfresh.com when I die I put
my money in the grave that's the teddy
fresh version delete my browser history
when I die
um the skirt that she's wearing I'm
wearing too right now
cargo skirt
skirt skirt
so much
do the rappers say skirt skirt
what does that mean they're talking
about this they're talking about skirts
driving sometimes driving in a skirt oh
it's about the wheels yeah
okay
yep got it but also the cargo skirt
this is a sick fire outfit man
it's like 100 degrees today in L.A so I
was forced to wear a short sleeve
but um
yeah love is loving this piece here yeah
the Chrome bear
we love it I think it's so sick I love
the 3D Vibe oh yeah
who else dad and the iconic
um Dan how did we call that sun
watercolor dye ice dye I think
watercolor dyed
uh Zach in the crop top
[Music]
Mash I tried to wear that one but I just
wasn't pulling it off frankly you were I
was so excited for you guys to be
matching wearing that I wasn't ready I
thought you were pulling it off okay
well
this is the only girly who matters
now look at this that's just a beautiful
plaid shirt right there boy I'll tell
you what man I've never seen goddamn no
goddamn plaid Jack like that boy
anyone else
yeah this is the one I have on screen
that one's great yeah beautiful
so sick hell yeah Sherpa right
it's warm today but it's worth it okay
these pants are fire I might need some
of these really yeah whoa and what is it
made of just corduroy oh it's corduroy
yeah oh damn
yeah I think I might very light corduroy
yeah can I get one of these oh yeah my
pleasure yeah I never pull pants for
Ethan so yeah yeah this is the first
time and I really like them history
they're really good they're really cool
I wonder what size you would be I don't
know because I'm going down to large now
in shirt size I don't think my waist
weirdly shrunk that much
but it did but
it did maybe it's like a 38 now instead
of like a 46. well we got your
measurements recently for the Streamys
that's true right you were a 46 waist
yeah dude it was nuts and almost fitting
into that good it was nuts my waist
my I've always had like a very
voluptuous waist size
damn and like even now there's no
question even now I'm like a 38 still I
would imagine
but I was 40 I mean I wasn't
even 48 yeah I think so goofy at one
point even though Spence we bought in
Vegas didn't fit yeah good for you man
that you should be proud of yourself
yeah well it was getting pretty dire I I
can't lie
oh there's a clip we're gonna watch
today from like a year ago when I was
it's weird I don't remember myself like
being looking like that
but we'll see it yeah delete I mean it
looks good on him he's trendier than my
ass
it's just the silhouette of this t-shirt
it's just a little more short so that's
what he's in Stockton friendier than
what I like to wear
um
what else we got yeah this Hat's fire
with the kovid thank you Zach said it
looks like covid or who was that yeah
thank you man for pointing that out you
guys don't remember this phone like when
we were younger I remember them it's
nostalgic it's a piercing yeah yeah
people used to have it in their belly
button yeah really I do it looks like
lint why would you want that in your bed
oh it's like silicone yeah it's like a
little species don't do that don't put
down your belly button it's better on
your hat
um this is cool we get kind of like a
retro long sleeve this sweater's by
super hot
this is our first shirt ever we issued
remastered anyone else got anything else
they wanna they're wearing I got the 404
on right now
all right click it
yellowing right now teddyfresh.com click
of the Year 1990. oh I have the um
striped shirt on oh yes yes girl yes my
favorite part is the back of it actually
let's see it
yes yes yes
oh there you have to do it
why'd they have to go that hard they
didn't have to do that I have the skirt
on the black Corner shirt it's really
cute
um Eva was wearing that and I thought
she looked so good today thank you very
nice
well done and you're wearing something
yeah this cardigan is a new colorway of
the old one this one is black would love
that I love it so classy so beautiful it
really is just such a beautiful piece
all right there that is oh here's the
clip speaking of which I was saying I
used to look different so here it is
right at the top
it's a clip somebody posted of me saying
I would get a tattoo if one of our dogs
passed away I don't know if this is
before we remember this this in fact it
must be before well it was the Rick and
Morty time when was that a long time ago
so Shredder wasn't even sick then the
shredder only got sick this year okay
well that's because I was like God
dude that's never gonna happen he's
gonna live forever
and uh
that didn't turn out to be true
but here I am uh
and let's call freeze frame on you
let's let's both listen to what I say
and how I look here
muted no audio play that again Zach all
right
100 pounds oh come on bro
okay well I was 5 11 300 pounds thank
you
dude five three three hundred pounds
okay they're out there I already went
down this road and they're like we look
we're fine I said yeah you're fine
anyway here I am I think the only thing
I've ever pack is like the memorial
tattoo
[Applause]
of who like if somebody died yeah I
didn't want to say it you know what I
mean that's what I mean I mean yeah so
like if the dogs die I didn't want to
say it because that's what I was
thinking because I was like you know
yeah God God forbid you know don't even
whisper that into the world
when the dogs die okay I'm gonna tap
them right but other than that something
that was like a very deep meaning
I'll definitely get a shredder and
Alfredo tattoo someday
I don't know what that is about but I'll
take it not much else going on for me
there yeah can you believe I mean it's
wow it's shocking yeah
I have this weird body image thing where
when I was really heavy
I didn't think I was heavy as I was and
when I was really fit I wasn't as fit as
I thought I was I thought it was heavier
is that weird
how'd you explain that
a form of body dysmorphia maybe there's
probably a way to describe that well
because when I was big I thought I was
not as big
isn't that the weird part I I compare
I'm the same way related okay really
that's that's so interesting because
when I look back at this I'm way heavier
than I remember seeing in the mirror
well when you looked in the mirror you
were just seeing you at the time you
weren't like oh this is Ethan plus X
many pounds you were just like oh this
is me you were used to it yeah
because I remember when the nickocado
thing came up and you're like you guys
aren't you're not that different that
like I was like what are you guys
saying right now yeah I think that's a
little far
even at the time but I guess it was a
multiple factors of what I
what I could when I'm looking pretty
heavy yeah and I only saw him from the
waist house I didn't know what he looked
like the rest of the body by the way
Nico caught us on a weight loss Journey
how's he looking these days I haven't
checked in a minute but he did look
great pull them up let's see what he's
looking like yeah
he's back on uh the avocado mukbangs and
the carrot mukbangs it was like a lot of
people in the chat are feeling the same
as you described okay so yeah so like if
the dogs
basically whatever's the the least
healthy way to view my body that's how I
do it
yeah
so um anyway the point of the video is
basically I said that I will get a
tattoo
two on our Shredder yeah
and I didn't forget about it people were
saying if they're curious if I
remembered saying this and I didn't I
did remember is the first thing I
it's not the first thing but I
immediately was thinking about it pretty
pretty recently and wondering
is this from Recently
two months ago reveal oh he's revealing
is this the reveal yeah
April okay 23.
so he's doing it looks like it's going
really well for him
you're joking but I I could tell that
he's lost a lot of way here I agree I'm
reading an article that says he lost 90
pounds 90. yeah he was much bigger than
that amazing oh my God I see he's not
really trying to look skinny now but 90
pounds my goodness keep going brother
yeah let's keep it going
well you can see it in his face when you
go
eight days ago it seems like he's okay
like can I just remind you that this guy
got mad at me for calling him for
talking about his body this man is
wearing a like
oxygen tank so that he can survive
eating a ton of takis whatever that is
what's talking why does he why is his
paint his lips black like he's lost
oxygen to his blood
look at this I'm downtown is like a
whole serious I see it stained his uh
lips like the tie from the talkies
it's weird it's some weird thing I don't
like him it's like kind of like a hot
Cheeto I guess would be the best but
it's blue oh much better so much better
blue heat is the flavor let's order one
I've never tried the blitz are pretty
good yeah they're just more more
flavored let's try it it's yummy but you
want us to order some Takis right now
yeah
okay
sure yeah good variety because like I
tried them for the first time ever like
a month ago
oh wow really
that's funny did not like it
um anyway so here this uh what love just
sent shows the uh yeah wow
that glow up though
he is glowing
get it brother we're rooting for you
all right come on Oliver could you
really always have to he's trying his
best
there's no need to
I was back at Takis
by the way Oliver Anthony was on uh
video Rogan oh yeah he did Jordan
Peterson's podcast that's what he did
wait oh who Oliver Anthony the fudge
round guy
who's after Joe Rogan yeah you're not
confusing it oh I had no he just did it
he just did it oh mister I'm not a
conservative I just do Tucker Jordan
Peterson yeah yeah Ray again and what's
his name was that was there anything
interesting there I haven't watched it
what's interesting was the thumbnail
Jordan Peterson got new teeth
yeah he did he got uh
he got a whole you know a head full of
uh say that I'm offensive sitter and
that I I need to have some sort of call
God look at it's already crying about
being offensive in the very beginning
action oh I see and I guess like if
there's anything that I would respond to
that with a Pharisee asked Jesus teacher
which is the greatest commandment in the
law and Jesus replied love the Lord your
God with all your heart with all your
souls
right fine this is the first and
greatest commandment and the second is
love your neighbor as yourself if we
could learn I'm sorry but like who
cares bro I'm not here for Bible
study man just play your damn banjo
like you know what I mean nobody wants
to watch this I don't think
go to Sunday school bruh
uh so here let me show you before and
after from Jordan's so here's Jordan's
teeth
um and you know they're not bad teeth it
looks like
he's been around you know those are the
kind of teeth that have been around the
block fold it you've had they've they've
went through a lot of confidence in
their time and sure
who am I to judge you know but I'll say
this his new teeth
they look good and look at that big
smile man you ain't never seen this man
smile like that look how happy his ass
is wow look face up what do you think
they actually look pretty good
because sometimes people get it and I
hate it I feel like it changed their
face oh those look good I think Jordan
got some good ass teas good Choppers he
looks like nicer he looks like I don't
know look at him I need teeth like that
can I do that your teeth are perfect I
need Jordan's doctor I don't like my
teeth you don't
I want the billion dollar smile I like
your teeth what I don't like is when I
smile yeah I feel like they don't
they're not big enough or something and
they don't show oh no don't get bigger
teeth that's when it changes your face
maybe it's my lip I don't know there's
something I don't like about my smile
your smile is very nice that looks good
yeah you just need it
that's beautiful that looks great you
should go get that snipped off I
actually had a very exciting visit at
the dentist exciting to me because my
whole life I've been so annoyed with
this front tooth that I have here
where I had to get a crown when I was
younger 18 in Israel and they put like a
it's like a iron piece underneath and
then the and then the ceramic tea tooth
and now the black is showing and so
every time I smile it's always like a
little black here and I've always been
so hyper aware of it oh I've never
noticed yeah really no it's not yeah
so I went to the to a dentist finally
about it and he was like oh it's so easy
we can we just today we don't use this
technology so there doesn't need to be
Iron under there and you don't need to
have the dark part underneath oh nice
and so but I'm pregnant so I can't do it
right now but because of the anesthesia
or why
um probably yeah probably that and also
just they don't want to risk any
procedure yeah because any procedure
could lead into infection or whatever
yeah yeah yeah at least not you know
yeah
so but that's interesting because I
remember you saw like a gum doctor and a
dentist about it like I don't know five
six years ago and they're like we have
experimental technology yeah I don't
know it sounded kind of like super
complicated back then I don't know why
it was so complicated I don't think they
knew what they were talking about yeah
regardless look at these beautiful
Chompers he's got man
look at that
uncle uncle Peterson is back baby
he's so back
and he's Found Jesus learn to make that
our priority it would resolve a lot of
the conflicts that have become like way
over complicated you know let's put him
in charge man God get a load of this
guy's ego
[Music]
Colleen man are you serious right now
that's bizarre that is really
speaking with musician Chris Lunsford
better known by his stage name
Oliver one thousand percent we should
film one of those yeah yeah Anthony
it's like Inside the Actor's Studio but
it's just him it's just all about him
Gus the balance between vision and
efficiency in artistics and this is him
with new teeth or old teeth well
Endeavors why the thumbnails no this is
new teeth era rich man north of Richmond
Richmond
but he's doing a bad job proving to us
that he's not conservative based on his
media tour
is really trying right he is really
trying and then he's like oh my next uh
my next guess my next podcast is a real
interesting God what's his name uh
Stephen King or what's the guy's name uh
Richard Spencer or something like that
real good interesting ideas Nick Fuentes
how did Stephen King get in the mixer I
just remember
not the author right yeah I I watched
something about him recently gotcha yeah
not the author
I was just I was searching for names I
was reaching into the dark for something
um so okay so yeah so here's what I was
talking about the tattoo
so I don't have any tattoos I don't know
what to expect from the process
I pretty much I started looking for
somebody
about a week ago
and I found someone in LA
it seems very good
and after some conversation and
conversing and
you know logistical planning
we have
decided
that I will be getting a portrait of
Shredder but not only that and I'll tell
you the date
on the 27th of this month Wednesday off
the rails I'll be doing it live on the
show
[Music]
and he says it'll take about five hours
so we got a good long episode we gotta
get to it you're trying to do the whole
thing in one session yeah
you don't think it's gonna have a shot
zero oh really chance why because it you
think it's just too painful yeah really
is it really painful
explain because I don't like pain it is
it is painful I
I think it'll be okay that spot it I
mean everywhere hurts but that's not as
bad as some other places I saw I was
looking at a tattoo pain tier list and
this was the least yeah because
definitely so much more oh I don't know
how much I got but somebody does like
compared to like right here then yeah
than this I mean you you got one here
right baby yeah yeah and that one that
one that was my first like big one that
one it was like about six hours and you
did it all at once yeah so why is it
that you think you're such a tough guy I
can do it and I can't well you already
had a bunch right Abe at that point
our very first one yeah no first big one
I had just the Arabic writing first but
gotcha my tattoo artist was very hard to
like uh schedule and all that and I had
a busy schedule so he was there I had to
just take advantage of it have him
finish up otherwise I felt like it would
have never been finished but you wanted
to bail
oh I definitely wanted to after about
like three hours like your adrenaline
Runs Out and like it at some point just
feels like someone's like axing off your
arm so what the am I gonna do
during the whole live show you think I'm
gonna be able to do the show I think
it's gonna be very good I think oh great
yeah sorry because your arm has to be
very still when they're doing it I'll
just feel like that because you can sit
where he lives sure I'll be like this
yeah I think it's gonna be difficult for
you to and I'm a baby too you know what
I mean that was what I was more exciting
is um well maybe if I wear pain
tolerance that seemsably low well right
and then that's probably true about me
I'm
but you know what can I do I mean the I
have to Soldier through
well I asked you guys I said is this a
good idea and everyone seemed to like
this do you want me to be here and yeah
um hold your hand
sure
thank you Lena maybe can I just get is
there can I get someone to give me like
a shot
why not I asked my artist that because
I'm like there's no way some people in
Hollywood are sitting through this and
he said that in Hollywood some people
get some sort of uh anesthetic or
something dude I saw the guys who do are
gonna do my tattoo it's like a whole
team of them and some people they put
them under because they do these massive
full-body jobs there's five of them
working on them at the same time
that's actually like why not the dentist
does that right yeah yeah at the place
where I get my tattoos they have like an
old like alcohol dispenser machine but
it's like out of commission and he
explained to me that
um you should not drink before getting a
tattoo because it makes you possibly
bleed more yeah drinking oh yeah what
water no no alcohol that's not a problem
there is numbing cream that people take
that's not enough that doesn't do
artists recommend it too anyways I don't
know if it why but they just recommend
against using it my artist once said
something he said you got to think about
it like a rite of passage and he was
giving me some history
is not gonna
that's pain is part of the process no
it's not a tattoo no what the are
you saying listen listen this is I'm not
trying to become a member of any club
okay I'm doing this for myself so that
when I get up in the morning when I'm
getting ready for work or whatever my
day that I see my dog right here in the
mirror and I never forget him okay I
mean it's not but I'm not trying to
Priority I approve myself
but like you know what I mean I I'm it's
under my sleeve I don't even want to
like you should ask him
if he can do a little
shot
I think you have to have some credential
he's just a tattoo guy I'll ask I'll
message him right now
because that would certainly make it
easier to do the show I'm I'm thinking
you know what I mean well that's a good
point
that is a very good point I am
by the way tomorrow night I'm flying to
New York for New York Fashion Week
that's awesome oh cool how do you call
that thought when it the numbing shot
what did the dentist call it a numbing
shot overcame novocaine novocaine is
that oh that's the type of shot you were
talking about I thought you meant an
alcohol shot oh I was like you want to
take a shot over the shop
no so is novocaine uh is that just for
the mouth or is that anywhere I don't no
I think the arm might be benzocaine
lidocaine lidocaine lidocaine don't lie
to me
lidocaine
a numbing shot
okay with that because that would be
great I have lidocaine cream that is
great really you want to use some is it
medical how do you get that no I got it
on Amazon I think but it's like a it's
it I don't feel anything when I put it
on it's great really yeah because I
don't believe I'm skeptical yeah I don't
believe well let's buy some of those I
have it in my car do you want to try it
yes okay let's do that right now that's
a good idea or maybe but I was gonna say
I'm returning back from New York Tuesday
night
so technically if you want I could be on
the show yes please I mean I need as
much sport as I can get although he's
going to be sitting here so we'll have
to set you up
we can set you up are you doing this arm
yeah
I think so you think I should do this
charm I don't know why I thought it
would be good I could do it on I can you
can sit here and then you can sit
should I do my left or right arm I don't
know
I was feeling a left arm I don't know
why
I will say if because you're
right-handed yeah that's a good question
right so um if you are trying to do a
live show well you're gonna get back to
having your right this one and available
would probably be helpful to trying to
do that
I can do it with my left hand though
yeah I mean this is a lifelong decision
so yeah I guess don't base it on your
convenience for one day but I always
imagined it on my right I don't really I
like that too it's like your primary arm
it's put it on my primary arm yeah it's
like a little bit symbolic yeah yeah
yeah yeah go for it yeah
okay okay what do we think do we like
the idea
do we like the idea or do we love the
idea because there's well it is off the
rails so people can't expect much
at least we're keeping it you know make
sure you moisturize your arm before I
have thick Italian hair and always get
some sort of ingrown hair or irritation
yikes
well I have I don't okay all right I'll
do that
um you're giving me tattoo fever I want
to get more now so do you like the pain
cam I don't like the pain but I like the
Artistry of it
I mean the pains whatever you just deal
with it I'm in pain I also don't do a
show what do you do during the process
cam I just closed my eyes and I try to
focus on the pain and just being mindful
of it focus on the pain yeah that's
hardcore I don't know
just focus on the pain bro that's sick
just I just closed my eyes and I feel it
you know these these were brutal
the fingers oh yeah honestly I was gonna
suggest that to you that placement but I
was like no Ethan wouldn't want my
fingers yeah how what finger is by far
the most painful I've ever done a
portrait there
oh a tiny little finger portrait yeah
it's so small I have like a butterfly
that has shading on my finger this one
hurts so bad the others I was
fine with this one it felt like someone
was just like scraping at my skin
horrible with Ethan I wasn't worried so
much about the whole tattoo just the
shading the shading is going to be
painful
well it's I'm getting a photo realistic
it's so and this guy seems are really
good oh yeah they'll be shading
but it's just black there's no color
it's just black yeah thank God
so glad you don't want color so you're
not down with color test
same
as muted that was one of your big like
things about uh about the Affleck tattoo
yeah I remember you you said color
tattoos in general you don't like in the
math like one in particular well I'm not
getting color I was never my plan I just
want a nice photo realistic uh you know
blacks grayscale what's the deal of
color I feel like you want to get
Shredder all over your
video it's a huge shredder like this I
don't want to do it on my back because I
would never see it I want to see it you
know what I mean sure
everyone vouches fingers are bad yeah
yeah I fingers and toes nothing is worse
than top of foot
oh I can imagine I could see that
hurting what about forehead
I feel like bring it Sam's got it all
right so how do we test this let's do it
on my now why do you just have that on
you Sam
oh was that painful
so this I just squeeze it and comes out
try a little bit because you you get all
these crazy rashes
that's enough
you want to do it yeah that's
funny yeah I'll be fine you're known to
have like these weird reactions to
things I think you should show it's fine
I put it all over me dude I never get
rashes my bad didn't exactly this happen
on an episode once like we put something
on it yeah
all right so how long do I wait now
and
how long does it last
usually like 30 to 45 minutes for me so
we'll have to be reapplying that a
little keep bluffing the bucket of that
boy
maybe he does know someone because like
I said here look I don't wanna
docks him yet obviously I'm
looking forward to promoting him when he
comes on but I don't necessarily want to
say it already you know what I mean yeah
people will go like
I don't know people yeah you just don't
know
um but what I will say is
I want to show you this one of the of
the person under with like five people
working on him so crazy they'll be able
to find don't know from that picture I
doubt it here
look at that
people are smart look at that yeah
that's crazy
there's like five people working on him
dude that's nuts is that normal for
multiple people to work on the same
tattoo at once I've never seen that
never seen it
okay there it is what do you guys think
lidocaine is super safe and gentle oh
sorry I was just saying that I used uh
numbing cream when I did my lip filler
and it did not help
me and I was like squeezing his hand the
whole time I'll give you like a little
tool to put against your face but that
wasn't helpful
dude the cream is both yeah I don't have
any faith in the cream I don't know you
know what I mean just skip the cream
was that real painful Lena
I think so yeah because the lips are
sensitive she was squeezing the out
of my hair yeah it was like a mix of the
pain and then also like the anticipation
because you don't you've never felt
anything like that before so I didn't
know what to expect is the needle in for
a while on the cream it's like you feel
like go in and then like stuff going
into your lips oh my God
it ain't easy being uh
there's a price to Beauty yeah
every budding Beauty
budding Beauty
yeah but if I can get the shots I'll
just do that hell yeah oh you know what
maybe that one doctor would do it for me
if you weren't doing the show I would
suggest like just taking a Xanax and
falling asleep
I don't know if that would help me
I would just still be in pain
they they did that one time for me at
the dentist oh yeah I'm saying it right
they gave you like a super valium or
something like passed out
you got Xanax like I mean I don't have
any no I don't know where to get me some
I mean I feel like this the tattoo
artist will know all this stuff no I
don't know but he's not a doctor well he
definitely knows
recommendations at least yeah yeah yo
bro can you get me some street drugs
like that you just showed him doing like
five people on a person that was put
under yeah so that they had a doctor
there clearly because you need an
anesthesias for that
I think you'll be okay yeah you'll
realize the least painful area well you
all got you're the ones that got me all
thinking about it everyone's
like oh boy I just remembered the period
simulator that's all I'm gonna say yeah
that was a weird one the show element is
really the curveball in my in my
people are saying ketamine what do you
guys think about that sure sure I mean
Xanax would be a fun episode that'd be
weird and wild yeah I don't know yeah I
don't trust young well I've got a black
button Personnel I think the pain would
be funny if it hurts for the show it's a
funny element I thought so too but if
it's number five I'm capacitated for
five hours yeah
are we really gonna do a five hour show
I feel like you're going to want to stop
at like half maybe what I was saying it
was like just do it in two sessions you
know
maybe we'll see I mean yeah if if I want
to we'll just obviously
deal with it later yep
cool cool right on sweet
so we'll get some ketamine some Xanax
yeah yeah yeah some lidocaine yeah yeah
I'll ask around
and uh what else fentanyl why not 2cb
crack shrooms track I'll smoke crack
with that one LSD acid you want to drop
back do you truly think that smoking
crack would help with the pain
that's why uh that's the guy I had sex
with I saw Obama Obama got hooked during
his first tattoo session
but yeah and a really long way to say
that I'm going to be getting the tattoo
on the show nice yeah so it's next
Wednesday no it's wait is it no no it's
oh I'm further away oh okay it's on the
27th so it's in okay like three three
weeks yeah yeah it's always up
there it is there it is I'm gonna get a
tattoo I never thought I would get a
tattoo I never did
tell you one
this is the only thing I would get it
for
is to
commemorate or memorialize
and it is really is truly for me
you know what I mean like I'm not trying
to
I know some people like they're part of
a culture no I'm not judging just saying
people they're they're tattoo people
I don't want to be a tattoo person don't
don't I don't want to be in anyone's
Club
okay the less clubs I'm in the better
and besides I want to want to be a part
of a club that would have me as a member
I was just pulling up the Groucho Marx
quote so that I didn't misquote it but
yeah you got to it first yeah I got that
one
so anyway moving on thank you so much we
gotta do our uh should this be Numb by
now Sam or it's not dry yet I don't
think it's been 10 minutes yet yeah it
takes a minute
start feeling kind of like tingly and
warm-ish okay when it's starting to work
maybe ELO could just slap your arm or
something I think we need something
Pokey
I think it's been 10 minutes actually
it has been 10 minutes yeah all right
let's do the ad and then we'll we'll
poke myself
cool love that foreign
thank you so much
to our wonderful sponsors today guys
please consider supporting them
today I want to thank big big thanks to
the one the only love them so much X
hexclad
[Applause]
hexclad has revolutionary
magical pants
it is Magic it is kind of the new
generation of cooking and
it's so sick I mean I've been using
these now probably for a year plus they
look brand new
and I'll tell you this I have never
owned a pan with this much like
durability I mean we've bought expensive
pans before they always get all messed
up man
but they they got some kind of
interesting technology here with the
hexes
the power of hexagons
baby
yeah the hexaclad power and so
here it is
it's expensive but you know it's
actually not I mean I was gonna say pans
are really expensive in general
so this is about I'd say mid-range in
terms of price
for example
a six set is four hundred dollars
which is
it's good chunk of change but it's Gonna
Last you it's a fairly priced for a
really good pan yeah and if your pans
are getting ruined in a year and you're
rebuying them every year you know what I
mean well we I remember our first night
pair we bought from Costco we bought
like the stainless steel it was like it
was about 600 yeah and I mean they don't
really the handles are falling off
they're getting all up
but check this out lifetime warranty
metal utensil safe
dude I've tested that like to be honest
I've been scared too still right and I
that's because I don't know not to do
that I'm so trained this sucks well
sometimes I'll not have a wooden spoon
or something yeah and I'll just use the
fork just go for it and it's all good
it's all good bro it's awesome it's all
good non-stick non-toxic oven safe
dishwasher safe induction ready
and the handle stays cool
stay cool stay cool stay cool
um
it's the perfect gift the perfect thing
to treat yourself for some good Home
Goods I'm just so in love with this
product and uh damn which pan is it that
you're cooking with
I guess it's just I have the normal like
medium-sized frying pan the one in the
middle here yeah yeah and uh and I have
some of the pots too hmm these are the
ones I use all the time is these ones
here Sam has the walk oh
your parents oh I really like it I have
the knives as well and I love them the
knives are so good the knives are the
best knives ever and I love the magnet
board they come on did you have this one
with the Magna board I don't have the
magnet board it's so good I want that
right there so just be able to throw the
knives and just have dude the magnet is
so strong it's so satisfying damn it's a
double-sided so both sides stick on the
on the wood board and this is what we
have in our kitchen right now and it's
fantastic it really is
um but
yeah I would recommend the pans big time
the knives are great too but
I'm just it's such a great company I
mean it's such a great product they've
got a lifetime warranty I mean who
offers that you know
it's fantastic forget about it
so um listen
let me tell you something
let me pull this up they got like
we watch the the Gordon Ramsay video
again
let's see what they got here for me
today
I fell in love with hex clouds a few
years tell me Gordon a chef friend of
mine said
tell me Gordon tell me everything I need
to know about 12-inch non-stick pan as a
gift it was a joy to work with something
that I took to immediately as a front
runner in the industry they're raising
the bar my level of perfection connects
with that bar and more importantly as a
collaboration together I think we will
become one of the most exciting brands
on the planet I'll say this Gordon
Ramsay he definitely chased that dollar
that man Works harder than anyone that
being said he would not endorse a
cooking product he didn't believe it
there's no shot man yeah he takes
cooking way too seriously and he's even
Gordon's out here saying it's all about
hexclad my dudes cheers my dudes
[Music]
um yeah
listen
find your Forever cookware at hexclad
get 10 off with the promo code after
dark
hexclad.com slash
after Dark
right there I'll say it again
hexclad.com after dark links in the
description uh
really love this product and thank you
to them and I hope you guys will
consider
supporting them thank you all thank you
thank you thank you
yes sir yes sir
[Music]
okay let's go next up thank you again to
another fantastic sponsor Shopify who I
cannot sing their praises enough Shopify
is the place you need to be if you're
thinking of opening any kind of
e-commerce no matter the scale small if
you've got plans to grow medium even
large
it's all happening on Shopify there
isn't a single e-commerce platform
uh that does what they do as good as how
they do it we are actually in the
process of updating our own team on
Shopify
and guess what the customers will have
no idea because they make it so easy
that we can work on it offline and then
when it's ready you just publish it and
it's seamless everybody even knows
anything happen one thing that always
surprised me that I I say it every time
never been offline yeah the website has
never gone down and that is a challenge
yeah to anyone out there it has never
gone down it's pretty wild
it's hosted by Shopify and so like
they're hosting potentials nuts yeah and
I mean we've had some big ass days like
when we do some of these black Fridays
there's a lot of traffic headed there
and the website runs
like what the hell yeah like the one I
think two years ago we were like the top
five oh yeah one of them shops that the
Black Friday top five the color block
hoodie was like one of the top selling
items for the year that's crazy for
Black Friday yeah
um I'm happy to say unfortunate that we
picked Shopify from was our very first
toy yeah we started somebody recommended
to us yeah I I remember looking around
and I remember Shopify just kept coming
up people were recommending it and it
just sounded so easy and I'm so glad I
did because yeah yeah I love it
basically the ability to scale our
business from what was essentially me
Ila and one person yeah up to what what
it is today was absolutely seamless
and easy easy they've got at an add-on
plug-in shop so you can buy these
add-ons and plugins for your shop to
level up the game and then these add-ons
are run they're developed and run by
Third parties so what's interesting is
like
you can get really high-end Services via
their add-on shop and it's so convenient
for example like
one of them just to give you guys an
example well the fraud protection one
was like a game changer for us that was
so easy to add on but even like for
little things like a dress correcting
like something that will pop up at the
end and make sure your address is
correct because oh yeah we used to run
into problems of people putting in the
wrong address and then reaching out can
I correct it and it's like the order
already went out you learn all these
little things as you run the business
you don't know what to expect and then
as we go people will tell me oh you know
you can install an app for that or you
can add a plugin for that and like
slowly you learn so much about it and
the reason I say it's good that it's run
by third person is because
they're they're they have their own
service customer support there and
they're there to make sure that it's
done perfectly on their end
so all these services are coming
together in this portal and it really
turns out to be
it's got to be the best service in the
game I mean it's just so good
then they've got like the shopping app
they've got we have we're doing all this
cool stuff with them
they've got now they even have their own
like um
they implemented a thing now where they
you can pay in installments you know if
I implemented that hmm
that's awesome man I gotta say if you
guys are in the market to make any kind
of e-commerce big or small
you got to go with Shopify and that's
just a no-brainer
um
we also have a deal here
check out this deal
[Music]
Shopify Powers 10 of all e-commerce
that's insane actually
rothby's brooklinen all birds
sign up for one dollar per month
that's a trial period of one dollar per
month for sure go to shopify.com after
dark all lower cases
go to shopify.com after dark to take
your business to the next level one
dollar per month trial that's awesome
um
it really you know and you should try it
at a dollar a month I mean what do you
got to lose it's it's gonna do a huge
huge benefits for you guys
uh so there it is love you Shopify thank
you so much for sponsoring us I hope you
guys will consider uh
signing up with them eh wow we've got
those talkies fast man
[Music]
oh my God wait how did that get here so
fast
holy thank you I love Takis all
right absolutely have I never heard of
it that's so surprising it's a Zoomer
product I think really they're so good
they've been around for a while because
I never heard of them either and then
all of a sudden everyone's eating Taco
Nitro
so I got a I saw a good suggestion in
this way though for your arm Ethan yeah
crunchy test it this way
can I shoot can I shoot you in the arm
sure yeah I got something to I'll grab
it hold on let's let's ease in let's
season you got to do both arms to
compare the pain too
[Music]
that's such a good point this is the
number
oh my God the flavor is too strong yeah
okay go ahead I'm gonna cover my eyes
too yeah here we go right here right
right here okay yeah
I felt that but now now on the left now
we have to compare I think you missed
the spot though oh really I think you
shot it you're there you gotta shoot it
like here
okay here we go get down
I felt it I mean I definitely felt it
there's no questions
yeah it's not gonna do anything yeah I
don't think I mean if that salt gun hurt
me
I got no shot
I need the doctor you already tried it
I tried that one crunchy fajita I've
tried every Takis product that exists
my problem with the talky
oh he says I can do it
he's laughing at me he goes we have a
nurse that can do it for two thousand
dollars oh my gosh he laughed at me he
said LOL but he says but the upper arm
is not painful so he's gonna judge me
two thousand dollars wait is that to put
you under no no that's for the shots
that's just it for the shot
what do you say maybe it's expensive I
mean clearly yeah it's probably because
only like big celebrities probably do it
but I think in this in the interest of
doing a show for the whole day I think I
should do that right for sure purposes
sure
I don't think I'll be able to do it yeah
it's for the show I think you can
I've seen you super sick and do the show
yeah I think you should go with the pain
it's fun you think what I think no shot
No in fact
yeah I think no shot
us can you have her on standby
the blue is kind of weird the flavor it
just has too much spice don't you think
the fajita flavor is fire I've never had
Takis before though this is my first
Taki
the nature sucks I don't like that one
at all the blue heat is kind of good
actually I only have a nice aftertaste I
haven't tried any others so the blue
heat I think is just supposed to be more
flavor
certainly not something I would want to
eat a mountain of though oh no like when
I think of mukbanging
I don't think of food like this
so the blue ones makes your poop blue
the blue one makes your poop blue no
yeah it's crazy that's disturbing
okay this one is called Fuego I pooped
my pants
the blue one even safe
I swear it's not
try this place I just did that's the
good one who's on fire no it is not yeah
it's like fire oh I like that one the
best why is there so much flavor in it
isn't this just the original flavor the
original Taki
yeah we go the fajita the the Fuego's
the original yeah holy chocolate
mocha
I think I tried them all I mean it's
okay I guess not gonna hate on it
oh I'm recording Nitro like
Nitro boat hit the Nitro switch
[Music]
it's not really the spice it's the
overwhelming
spices
so let's do a poll if people think I
should do the shot or not I know y'all
gonna say no but but that's how you're
handling the Takis it's not hot it's
just the spice bro my favorite is the
crunchy fajita
you haven't tried it
oh stuck in my throat I'm out I'm
talking
let's do a pulse someone doing that
one sec
so
don't you guys think it might be a good
idea to just have them on standby
you know what I mean
other than doing like an hour-long show
where I'm like I can't do this you guys
I'm crying I'm a grown man crying
I can't do it
is it close to the Hot Chip not at all
that's a weird question give me a break
oh that's cool that they have the option
though I appreciate that even though
it's like insanely expensive yeah I
voted yes
no okay but then like okay people that
voted no consider that fact that it
might just be an hour-long show where
I'm like I'll I'll I'll I'll I
[Laughter]
cause the thing is is if I have the
nurse here
I'll start without the shot and then you
guys can see but don't you pay just to
have it here
I'm gonna use it but I can do like 30
minutes without just so that they can
watch me suffer hmm
yeah I think they just want to watch The
Suffering that's why they say no you can
watch me suffer for 30 minutes
2K would change my life someone said
well
uh send us your
email one of the mods
I'll send you two thousand
Mr Beast up in this who said that
where's that comment I have my favorite
comment
2K would change my life it's uh quick
coup you guys see this
if you are message one of the mods on
Discord I'll send you two thousand right
what do you mean yeah it I'm Mr
Beast on this I feel you know what
I mean like if I'm gonna waste 2000 or
I'm trying to spend two thousand dollars
in some dumb then you know what I
mean
we should help out our fellow people as
well
[Music]
this is a show expense to be fair
all for you guys
also we sent we paid off uh did those
people we paid for the their medical
bills ever
yeah
I'm very appreciative okay that's good
sorry guys I'm just Mr beasting this
I read it what happened is I read it and
then I felt bad and I said you're right
so let me just send you the money
50 now everyone's saying hundred
thousand we changed my life two thought
yeah
two thousand we changed my life
set but yeah if you're if you're
watching reach out to one of the mods
you guys gonna hit his name because yeah
I got his channel okay good good thank
you love
there it is
um but only if you've recorded okay
here's the deal if I send you two
thousand you need to record yourself
crying at home
thanking me
you I wanna you need to tell me exactly
how you're going to spend the money and
it needs to pending my approval okay you
can only spend it out I authorize its
use
thank you
all right God where have we we haven't
done any thing nothing right
who cares
we're having fun that's true we do have
stuff we need to get to but
speaking of Jordan he posted a mug shot
I don't even get why he did this it's
not even funny it's just weird
he posted a really horrible Photoshop of
him on Trump oh okay mug shot
yeah why he said the Ontario College of
a psycho psychology psychologist ordered
me in for my mug shot today
it doesn't it's not it doesn't even look
good at all
I don't know what's supposed to be funny
and it has 33 000 likes like there's
these people out there I just
just question man who's liking this
and then he posted a black and white
version for no reason it's not better
it's not even different why did you post
that one too he's unwell he is not well
this man
oh why did he do this did he think this
was so substantially more interesting
that he had to post it honestly you have
options you know
he likes the LARP as a victim thought
provoke him
old timey Peterson
um Cav cat speaking of is he feeling
okay Kev keeps psycho posting
so did you see his recent one about the
world government conspiracy I was
watching the show okay so he did another
one watch this I agree with you when you
were like what do you do if somebody in
your life starts posting this like damn
we lost we lost another one how about
somebody who you gave a bunch of money
to starts posting this yeah that would
be worrying people actually invest with
him how
I you know who I want to talk to one of
kevcab's investors I want to talk to
them
right just giving this guy money except
his dad
okay so here's kavkav he's posting Bill
Gates
food conspiracies
potatoes for McDonald's fries are
reportedly grown on Bill Gates farmland
and Fields so vast that you can see them
from space yeah that's probably true
right it is true I looked it up yeah but
that's that then but there's so much
more to that his conclusion is where it
goes off the rails right yeah
so he says
so hashtag Bill Gates oh that's good he
hashtag it let's bring all the Bill
Gates people together
so Bill Gates is literally responsible
for McDonald's hashtag McDonald's
he's a genius on social media yeah let's
get that traffic
cracks me up when people do that uh for
hashtag McDonald's okay Bill Gates is
literally responsible for McDonald's
french fries yes they are the best
tasting thing ever which have shown to
be one of the worst things you can ever
put in your body oh yeah and he is the
primary supporter researcher and Science
and beneficiary behind the vaccine
too much wine how do we go from potato
to the vaccine well he's blaming
McDonald's for what they do with his
potatoes yeah it's all weird
but second of all
so I I just Googled like Bill Gates
potatoes just to see and it's like so
that him and his wife they invested in a
bunch of farms which is weird and creepy
it's a little creepy yeah but it's just
an investment and they have they don't
not only grow potatoes yeah a bunch of
other things well he he makes it that
everybody uses for everything he makes
it sound like Bill Gates is behind the
big french fry to kill people
I love how he admits they are bomb
yeah they are super bomb
but then he goes oh yeah he's the
primary supporter researcher in science
and beneficiary behind the vaccine what
how do you go through the vaccine
nothing to see here he says it's all
connected guys bro don't you are you
beginning to understand
[Music]
the brain is made of potatoes grown on
Bill Gates you'd have a higher IQ of
Bill Gates potatoes like there's
Farmland that's so vast that can be seen
from space I mean yeah it's just like
all of Google maps I mean that's ever
anywhere in the country where there's
Farmland right like yeah I mean there's
a lot of Farmland in America before Bill
Gates you can see a lot of things from
space with the with the satellite right
this person said
uh I'm not a supporter of the vaccine
either but what does McDonald's potatoes
have to do with the vaccine exactly and
this is one of his allies apparently
Ryan responded to be clear I got
vaccinated I was a supporter Bill Gates
is the primary business driving force
behind mRNA vaccines and really pushed
them through for covet because he quote
cares so much about our health yet he
also uh is one who delivers McDonald's
french fries to the world clear
no do you his brand is so powerful wait
Crystal wait how are you
please if you know someone investing in
Ryan Kavanaugh send them this this man
is is not well this this is the this is
the article yeah the one that I read
cool it's just like whoa yeah you can
see that from space
right so that's what I'm saying that's
this is this is where this originates
from you can see everything from space
like it's correct people sunbathing in
their backyard from space indeed I think
Billy uh needs to get back on that poop
water I didn't like the poop that's the
future what happened to the poop water
initiative
I think they're I think they're cleaning
that dude I think they're cleaning
that water still because I always
thought that was a cool idea
you know revolutionary but it's like if
you want to criticize Bill Gates about
the Farms I'm sure there's another way
to do it that would make sense but why
the potatoes and McDonald's I don't get
it dude it's it's connecting it to the
vaccines yeah and then the vaccine it's
borderline like um
psychosis thinking yeah it's so good
it's like reality yeah but it truly
makes me wonder if this man is okay I
don't think he is there's a video I I
don't think we could show it he posted
on his Instagram of his helicopter
hitting a bird and he well the bird is
dead and he's picking the bird out of
the helicopter yeah it's like its head
looks like it's barely attached send it
to me
that was on Instagram yeah yeah he
throws it at the cameraman wait what's
recording what he's desecrating dead
Corpses
that's like okay
screen it first okay no I'm not gonna
show it all right so here he is this was
posted uh five days ago here you can
watch here
so ever wonder what happens when a bird
just misses your rotor blade this man
can still afford to cruise in
helicopters yeah I don't get it
dude if you ever believed in meritocracy
as a concept
which I don't think a lot of our fans do
at this point
but if you did Ryan Kavanaugh
single-handedly
dispels dispels this idea
if there was a meritocracy Ryan
Kavanaugh would be
you'd be cleaning dead birds off of
windshields I don't even want to I don't
want to denigrate anyone's job sure but
what but he would be like um
our Animal Control friends
and the freeway our garbage men well
like a like a prisoner he's like well no
it's just a minimum wage because they're
you know it could work for Caltrans so
that seems like a good spot Caltrans
I disagree I think Ryan's doing a public
service
by killing birds yeah oh I see that's
interesting
I stand Ryan on this yeah
no no no
posted just flying along Coastline
minding our own business and asigo
decided to Kamikaze us and had to do an
emergency landing all right so let's
watch feeding out the bird guts from the
intake
all right the unnatural thing in the sky
was the bird
oh bare hands he's picking up the bird
corpse
and he threw it at the cameraman which
is actually really so crazy
yeah I wouldn't show this
I mean
yeah you really don't throw dead bodies
at people
I thought that was we'd learned that in
first grade bro oh you sick oh
very soon you say Ethan
God everyone hates him probably his
cameraman hates him
everybody hates you Ryan
there's a dick move to throw a
bird though the top comment is Ryan
cabron is a force of nature Harvey
Weinstein oh my God
is a force of nature
oh here he is with Grimace what are they
doing
inside her info put the shooting movie
together
oh is he going to be in Bryce's new
movie yeah okay interesting well you
know the Grimace created a shake and
apparently it was doing harm to people
that's a conspiracy theory right there
bro I had I had Skittles
yesterday
who's making the sugarcane
Against Humanity
Grimace side note he has another video
from August 15th of a of a bird
a man's head send me that what
send me all the I'll privately screen it
so he's always been not okay dude
yeah I think ever since relativity went
bankrupt he probably was less okay
three weeks ago he said um has to be the
funniest and craziest thing I've seen
all week a bird shagging a man not
joking a bird having sex with a
photographer on live TV okay let's see
if it's not far and by the way YouTube
people this is a BBC nature clip so give
me a break please also this is
not live television
I know Ryan doesn't know a lot about
Media or
the entertainment industry
live from the uh this is a nature
documentary Live From The Heart of the
Amazon forest
dumbass you want me to mute the audio no
a typical male Sirocco is clearly only
interested in one thing that's not that
interesting look at the comments wow
what a nice capture
super real 50 gifted subbies from a
membership will change your life thank
you
that's probably our benefactor
oh wait how many they say they get way
more than that 150. thank you thank you
thank you thank you it's changing our
lives
200. thank you oh my goodness he's still
going thank you man a membership will
change your life thank you so generous
and it's so nice thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you
can we advertise being a member that you
might win two thousand dollars now since
I remember dead that is a potential
person I've not heard from that member
yet
you're still watching that's pretty cool
so yeah cavca's not doing well send him
your thoughts and prayers just your
thoughts and prayers not not anything
physical yeah thank you but untangible
things in life thoughts and prayers you
send to Ryan Kavanaugh right and
positive energy we're all rooting for
him thank you the words of Joe Biden
I think we're up to 300 dude
300 still going damn thanks bro
300 yes 300. that's so nice wow
it seems like the uh
the Royal Saudi Investment firm just
made an investment in the agency
we shouldn't talk about that on the air
though
oh yes Mom's the Word wink well dude
he's still what the hell how can you
even do that how does your credit card
even let you do that how do you not get
frauds how many is that baby I think he
said once that he had to stop because
his credit card stopped working yeah
yeah good thank you that was amazing so
how much was that at least 500 I think I
think it's 500.
thank you thank you this is a serious
message to all new members you're
welcome to all the new members that are
getting hooked up right now all new men
please with peace and love I will see
you on Tuesday
thank you thank you
that's awesome I have to go wash my
hands after these The Talky explosion I
gotta tell you I wasn't I wasn't that
hard on these
yeah not the best it's a Zoomer thing
it's a Zoomer thing I genuinely believe
it's a Zoomer I mean I like I like like
the flavoring the powder but the the
actual stick in there is not very good
so you should try the blue ones
yeah like I don't mind the how spicy it
is okay let me ask this everyone who
loves Takis raise your hand the two
Zoomers hands up that's it interesting
I'm telling you bro well uh Ian and Sam
are Zoomers right oh Cam has it up too
okay all right young at heart young at
heart right
salmon wait how many inner tumors are
you like making fun of me Dan or what is
this like I think I'm a Zoomer I'm not a
Zoomer I was born in 97 I'm 25. yeah Sam
definitely is I'm not a Zoomer no she's
not a Zoomer Zoomer like people are in
high school right now aren't they no no
Olivia's a Zoomer daughters are like in
their 20s Sam's only one year older yeah
that's not a Doomer I'm sorry they're
this almost the same age how old are you
Olivia I'm 24. and how old are you Sam
25 25 I'm about to be 26. I don't think
Olivia or Sam hold on hold on one person
born in the late 1990s or late 1990s
exactly or or early 2000s what's your
birth year love 2000. oh you're hella
Zoomer yeah zoom zoom baby
what's your birth year I think 99.
you're a Zoomer no I'm Sam what's your
birth year 97.
close
she's an elder Zoomer yeah you're on the
cusp
you're on the cusp what's the actual
definition
he just said just somebody born in the
late 1990s through what mid-2000s yeah
Millennials is 81 to 96 so
right
okay yo the fact that you're born in
2000 a Cod I I hate to even start doing
this because it's so cheesy but man I
was like fully alive when you were born
I was like a full ass person yeah I was
15. I don't remember 9 11 Doug you were
15 until it's crazy right okay yeah I
mean I was like 13. yeah I was like
almost
done with high school almost yeah middle
of high school yeah I wasn't even
conscious back then
crazy bro for like 2010. I was playing
EverQuest before you were even born dude
you probably had a job before I was
conscious
yeah God damn yeah probably bro I didn't
get in Consciousness until like 2010
right that's the other thing is when you
think about like where do you even
remember yeah from yeah when you don't
remember anything from before you were
10 years old
nah what nothing I don't remember
anything from like under I would say
five
anything before five is a black maybe
very scary memories of under five but
yeah it's more like I it's in there but
I don't like is that me I wasn't
conscious back then I'm not sure I know
what you mean I feel the same acting on
uh impulses and stuff like that you know
I have memories though yeah
so anyway I think I have to do the shot
because I I made I made the uh tribute
to our fan so now I can we feel comfort
and spending 2 000 on the shot
for the sake of the show people
for the sake of the show
yeah I can't deny that it would probably
go better if you were numbed up because
I'll try it you're just gonna be
squealing in pain probably I want to do
like a normal show you know yeah if that
if you really want to do that you should
probably get the shot
he's gonna think I'm the biggest
ever sorry to denigrate the you
know I mean I don't like that word
because
turns out uh people with are
probably the toughest of them all
or maybe
another way you're a bunch of a
sea bearing uh oh yeah things with bare
vagina
oh yeah uh
okay I'm gonna do it it at least
I've seen what a vagina looks like
I mean she has to sit with us the whole
time I guess it
I am curious about how um whatever you
want to show I'm just saying
yeah a little Scotty
sure yeah we got a Scotty update
oh
this is crazy
oh usually these are just yeah this
looks like a tiny little little base
yeah give me one sec just downloading it
so how far along are you now I mean I
know you're doing April I am beginning
of April
I don't remember but I have a nap
I'm almost 10 weeks
still real early the size of an olive
right now
still super crazy you're starting to
show a little bit I think
[Music]
thank you
it's like a baby apparently the doctor
said you can already like tell it's a
boy
[Music]
which is kind of wild we would have
known the agenda already it usually
takes longer they probably wouldn't tell
you though for sure they wouldn't say
anything just based on this yeah but
because we are no right
so is that it's limbs or is it just like
a visual yeah oh really that's what you
think it is the head head body and two
arms and two legs three arms wow
[Laughter]
so there it is little Scotty
pretty good already yeah pretty cool
okay here's a weird one Jimmy Lee
is is collaborating with Andrew Callahan
of channel five I I didn't know anything
about this nobody mentioned this to me
and I still don't understand what the
is going on it's very the situation
is very confusing I don't understand the
context I understand how they met I
don't understand why why Andrew was
doing a piece with with Jimmy I don't
understand and like as we'll see it's
like
and it's like footage of Andrew
interviewing Jimmy but it's Jimmy's
documentary because you know Jimmy films
everything he just Andrew went there to
film something for himself Jimmy brought
his crew and put the footage out first
well according to Jimmy Andrew reached
out to him
that I believe that's what I would think
yeah yeah
um I mean it's it's wait wait you just
we're taking Jimmy's word for that I I
don't know what to believe with him he
Andrew wouldn't just meet with Jimmy
unless you wanted to no hold on they
must have met on the street or something
that's see that's what I think
he just ran you're at that convention or
something I think the documentarian has
a little Insider info that's my guess
yeah that's gonna be here it's way too
much of a coincidence yeah it's also
apparently it's called I don't know if
this I don't know if this is Jimmy's
title or he or it's Andrew's title just
Almost Famous just about famous that
doesn't seem like a very good title from
my understanding I don't think this is
gonna be
associated with channel five
I think this is it just happened to be
in the the time in the place
but he's like in the thumbnail so wait
Andrew's not gonna use this footage I I
couldn't Jimmy wouldn't give me a
straight answer with it can we try to
call him
he's coming next week he's coming I
gotta know
I'll just ask him real fast what's he
doing here next week it's never real
Sami Quinn said I'm 33 weeks spooky baby
planning on treating myself to some
Teddy fresh as postpartum love
we can oh yeah let's send her stuff yeah
I'd love to send you stuff Jamie Quinn
reach out to the mods good luck that's
like right right at the end
I'm about to Mr Beast Mrs Beast your ass
damn
[Music]
I see a couple Chatters said that they
are getting close to their due dates
congratulations let's get those Super
Troopers out let's get those young
babies those young H3 fans
epidural with Theodore or Bruce I did
with Theodore and then with Bruce I had
no time it was all happening too fast
and um
honestly it was my biggest fear but
thinking back on it it just happened so
fast it's like a blur now I barely even
remember what happened
and so
I don't know if I have time though I I
will
based on the last one I don't think you
that was nuts
yeah but I'm gonna need a I'm not gonna
be able to feel this I can't deal with
the pain so look how red you got from
that this is from the gun yeah yeah damn
what the man that's right my
beautiful skin Alice would we know
what have you gone in to get the tattoo
with that cream expecting yep you know
you're right now you know you need the
shot it was important it was important
all in the service of science
but how do so is there a way to numb my
filter before the shot how do we numb it
for the shot itself
what is this cam
there's talk of next-gen oh my God it
looks so much higher resolution image we
cleaned it up you photoshopped a little
bit
CSI Style
thank you that's what we got going on
all right so let's watch this
documentary trailer
look at that hairline boy look at that
looking fresh
what are these glasses I don't know but
he's slaying right now Jimmy Lee is a
funny guy he sure is
got that old-timey piano
he's got a different glass
Olive Tree yeah restaurant I was gonna
say is that a reference that's the Olive
Tree website we go to
no no no Olive Tree is a Bible
it's funny he's everywhere all the
trees everywhere this didn't get claimed
right Zach uh no claim yeah the other
thing about Jimmy's he's a really a
fantastic piano player he's all right
playing that old-timey Tunes love that
yeah
really that one I love by everybody I
feel I have a gift
okay is he leaning into that now I think
so because he's not even doing that for
us I mean I got nothing good like in
there just in the office setting
I think he just Embraces it is what it
is yeah like he knows it's
batshit but like
I mean it's his thing you know but he
said last time on the show that he's
gonna do hair plant right
like he's gonna get a hair system I
think he said that last time he called
in there's no way in hell he thinks that
looks good it just can't I think so I
think he does look he thinks it's good I
think he just looks at himself in the
mirror a very specific way right and if
he looks if he sees him yeah looking
good then he's in the zone it really
just is it very blurred yeah I was gonna
say maybe his vision's receding too
[Music]
I like Jimmy to be the star of the show
yeah because he is the star he wants to
be a star he is this and if he's not
Jimmy you better clear this with me bro
I love how it's just you're narrating
the whole documentary
I'm not I did not uh endorse this
documentary so on Whose channel is this
uh wait yeah who is Alex yeah he's this
guy I guess that hit up Jimmy and um he
makes really good videos too I screen
some wait seriously yeah so he's working
with a Creator on this I guess yeah what
but I thought we were talking about
Andrew I don't understand anything well
yeah you'll see Andrew is in this later
in the trailer just okay kind of
randomly just oh randomly yeah and look
he's in the thumbnail too that's why I
thought it was his video okay it may be
just that he has a brief Cameo with this
guy Alex no oh
he's the documentarian okay yeah and he
makes really good videos
what on Earth okay okay
what was this Alan dershowitz videos
yeah I did that's actually the one yeah
what'd you learn about the dirt yeah new
interview and then uh hype uh hit him
with a surprise question about Epstein
yo that's pretty epic yeah you should
yeah I'd recommend it oh is this a sad
Jimmy are we seeing a sad side that's
what I say that's interesting My worry
is I have the real person under there
really well known before I die because
no one will remember me as a dentist
okay so I wonder if Alex put him up to
it then to the hairline thing because
that would be a good element for the
documentary I think Jimmy just thought
I'm a star of a documentary I gotta get
my hair and makeup done forever I'm
showing up that's just his luck but he
never wrote it that low until we were
like
encouraging him to go for it I think
this is his uh his makeup for his
character okay if he would I'm not
referring to him as a clown I'm saying
if he was a clown his makeup is on he
became a different person take it easy
don't push I was in the room with him
when we did when he did the day out with
him he became a different person when
that hairline came on yep it was a nice
old sweet old man and then when that
hair came on he was harassing the hair
and makeup guy
you know what it is he's like a gremlin
but but doctor day right Dr James weiner
is coming on Wednesday not Jimmy Lee oh
really specifically Jimmy Lee is not
well he's not well we want James weiner
because he's going to co-host with me
and the last time was fantastic yeah
last time I loved it yeah it was great
he really well known before I die
because no one will remember me as a
dentist but I need to carry a legacy on
the people remember me as the guy in the
street and was the wise guy to find it
dude okay now why is God look at his
hair
I've never seen those look how big the
strictly Adidas but I've never seen that
from Adidas yeah I didn't knock off I
think no I'm not because I remember when
he got it he got it from the store and
uh on uh Melrose
that's crazy stood out to me yeah like
I'm telling you I I know everything and
this is I've never seen that that's a
huge zipper yeah there's big gaps the
pocket too
why guy the funny guy but a good guy
that I need to know everybody knows me
and loves me we're here to see you no
you're not no we're dead serious
[Music]
oh it's a Jeremy Scott Adidas oh so he
got that official swag didn't he say he
was hooked up that they gave it to him
was on the show that's full of yeah
hooked up with his credit card oh look
at that he's harassing this poor girl uh
doing Street comedy take your thing off
your baby thing let me see how pretty or
take the baby off don't touch her bro
just to clarify as a Muslim woman she's
not even really supposed to be touched
by him at all why are you touching her
stop bro or a covered woman religious
yeah I like it all the time of course
she's religious
wait what did he say here
hold on he said some crazy here I'm
sure of it
God Jimmy and never learn yeah I like it
better than my regular job oh that was
just a cross cut
dentist in Italy dentista he's a dentist
we can play the piano he can sing he's
got the the comedy when you think of the
tote okay so this is big this is bigger
this is new Jimmy
whoa this what Larry wiener whoa
Jimmy's brother I want to talk to Larry
okay so wait because we got a Larry
unlocked didn't he say he he had a
fractured family with his brother he is
this a different brother
I can't recall I think if I could I
could be wrong I believe there are three
siblings total Jimmy Larry and I think
okay another one God he looks just like
him but he's just he decided to stop
holding on to them he decided to grow up
the growing up one you're not fooling me
they hired Stanley Tucci to play his
brother
when I look at him I see Jim Carrey
yeah all right let's see quality of what
the kid has it's resilience true yeah
huge lore alive why this is Mason they
got mace
okay so the last time we did the live
show Jimmy facetimed me with him oh oh
so you have had yeah okay okay I think
it's a decoy dude this is the same kid
you know this is a decoy it's the same
dude paid actor growing and stuff and I
think it's a whole different ballpark
that we're in with Jimmy because it's
all about Jimmy Lee what does it mean to
be from New Jersey okay so what happened
here this I'm so curious about the
comedy when you think of sorry
obviously he's not famous right now but
he's growing and stuff and I think it's
a whole different part that we're in
with Jimmy because it's all about Jimmy
Lee what does it mean to be from New
Jersey it's a lot of energy a lot of
fomo you have any Jersey jokes in your
mind do you know what uh Delaware wore
to the uh to the party what for New
Jersey
okay now you want to get to the funny
ones South Philly is still Italian so
you still have these kind of like
talking guys it's like a time machine no
one okay I'm pretty sure yeah they must
have just met him
maybe he did a call out for people I
don't think they're involved in any
official capacity I can tell you hey
there's no space for this in the
discussion unless they want to weaponize
like a nebulous mob of haters against
you
[Music]
who Andrew
is that what you're saying yeah I said
he's looking real good real healthy is
that a that's a ironic statement yeah it
doesn't look bad you just cut his hair
looks fine
World War II to the uh to the party
he looks fine
it's fine you just cut his hair man
tough crowd geez Louise New Jersey
[Music]
okay
South Philly is still Italian so you
still have these kind of like
talking guys it's like a time machine no
one can tell you hey there's no space
for this one too much sorry guys
nebulous mob of haters against you
and just about famous
Sundance in uh December
so uh no it's not I'm just kidding I'm
looking forward to it I'll watch it
yeah
Jimmy Lee like you've never seen him
before it says I highly doubt that
I've seen every single
uh iteration of Jimmy Lee by now I
thought anyway
all right very exciting mm-hmm
Judgment Day this is good the animation
[Applause]
this was made by animator uh Pantry
their main channel has close to a
million subs and I guess this was a
passion project
that they were too embarrassed to post
to their main Channel which I understand
which is a H3 fan animation
so here we go
three billion human lives ended on
August 29th 2083.
the survivors of the nuclear fire called
The War Judgment Day
they lived only to face A New Nightmare
against the low spots yeah
[Music]
wait it looks so good yeah
if you did that everyone saw that
dynamic
[Music]
you don't want to hear from Arizona yeah
this is horriform
[Music]
thank you
thank you for putting the time into
editing this that was awesome for
Nothing But Love of the Game
that's why it's not okay yeah there's
more holy crap post-credit scene oh
they're button
I think you're gonna dunk on press this
button right here
no oh oh he's going back in time yeah
oh that's so good that's awesome
well done well done Bravo yes Bravo
Bravo
this uh this is the second channel so
Padme is the main Channel
yeah main Channel's here Pantry Pantry
we love Pantry don't we folks yeah now a
real friend of the show out here
we watch one of his videos just to give
him uh some love let's see let's see
that was awesome
Minecraft in a nutshell 40 50 million
views whoa this doesn't have Minecraft
sex in it does it remember that well I
remember that but I don't think this is
you probably should screen these just in
case before I guess
Steve I must find the diamond and
building house
wow wow wow wow I am building a house
[Music]
wow wow wow wow I have found the diamond
yes
yeah I have found the diamond and
built-in house
I'm a crapper imma blow your house and
the Diamond
oh no
explosion sounds and pixelated
explosions
don't know me house and Diamond I am
dead
[Music]
haha yes plot twist it's me Santiago
there it is
damn true everybody very good
uh fantastic we love it there it is
Friends of the show
moving on I guess we should probably
move on to something one of our main
stories here it's already 350. talk
about something in the title
I mean the high school alone lunch money
thing was pretty crazy
this is gonna blow your mind I don't
know if you heard this conversation
I don't think I have
we were talking about how in elementary
school yeah lunch costs 35 cents
and if you didn't have the money they
they wouldn't feed you really 35
cents and then you could get a loan in
the office so some people started
sharing their stories
and uh
this one stood out to me and I'm sure
it's true and this is probably even I
would say common for people our age
at my high school you could be loan
lunch money two times if you tried more
than that they'd throw the food away
instead of letting you eat it
thousand percent they would do that a
thousand percent I feel like I've seen
that it's like this there's this famous
scene from Grapes of Wrath during the
Depression they were burning oranges and
extra produce because they didn't want
to give it away for free while people
were starving to death
it's like this is happening in
elementary schools
um at my school a girl had already
borrowed her lunch twice she forgot she
hadn't paid off from the last time
before she got to the checkout line when
she said she didn't have money they took
the lunch straight from her hands and
dumped it into the garbage right in
front of her because they couldn't put
the food back Jesus hearing them talk
about school lunch reminds me of that
they would rather waste food than let
you eat it that is like that's so dumb
so sick
it's a child and it's so humiliating too
to feel that stuff so deep
I remember I was I was really
embarrassed when I at times when I
didn't have the money
but to get be humiliated how could you
even do that as a person we don't have a
food
um court and
Israel at the school is there food at
all what you just bring or just bring
food with you there's no food there at
all
interesting
at my school they would let you rack up
lunch loans to a point but if you had an
unpaid balance you were not allowed to
go on field trips attend school dances
or get a yearbook to do this and at the
end of senior year if you still had
lunch balance they wouldn't give you
your diploma so serious no graduation
for you hungry poor peasants oh my God
it's so like insanely serious or for
what well and like for most of the
people that work in like the kitchens or
like volunteers of people like how can
you look at a child in the face and then
dump their lunch in the trash
yeah oh my God
so evil thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
nice
golly dude yeah when I was at school I
didn't have in Middle School
specifically they they sold pizza slices
and I survived on the generosity of my
friends giving me one of their
pepperonis
I've had over 40 pizzas in the last 30
days
ugh
embarrassing
to beg for pepperonis
this person says they're pushing kids
for something that is the parent's
responsibility if you're bored you get a
free lunch like I did but some people's
parents have money but just don't give a
about their kids which is kind of
where I was probably more so let's get
out of here let's go
um but like I said California just
became
I think the first state in the country
that offers free breakfast and lunch to
everybody really that's cool yep wow
that's awesome California baby I thought
we'd do it around here
love that I do love that
that is correct yep first date
huh I said yeah that's correct first
date
um
the first state in this beautiful Nation
That's it man you taught hey next time
someone talks about California and
say
well they give every kid free breakfast
and lunch at school
and then Joe Rogan be like that's
because you need to learn to
they need to learn to suffer you
know what I mean gotta earn ain't no
such thing as a free lunch free fight
even if you five
gotta work for it bro
got a pig for pepperoni like I used to
know
I don't want to pay for kids lunches
there actually are people who are like
very opposed to free school lunches
because they think
they don't want to support other
people's kids oh my gosh they go my kids
aren't doing the free lunch because
they're I feed them so why should I feed
other people's kids it's like psycho
it's crazy I go I'm seeing that one
school lunch costs three dollars
dude it's very expensive to feed kids in
the country it's very very expensive
yeah but just consider out what else
crazy stuff I know like on a person by
person basis but it's probably I'm sure
it's costing like tens of billions of
dollars probably per year yeah but I
don't know what's the budget on this on
the lunch program in California let's
see it's probably yeah I don't know I
think it's little it's so easy to spend
three dollars in my opinion for like a
government on that child well to stay
right so we have a state budget that
we're stepping into
also there's like 60 million people in
California yeah
how is this yeah yeah it's very free in
Sweden
completely are you looking into that
yeah
um
going through the bill right now you
know that's six dollars a day
for every kid
oh there's no way it's six dollars a day
per kid well love was saying it's three
dollars per meal five dollars if you
count breakfast usually five dollars per
day yeah so I mean every kid in
elementary middle and high school five
dollars a day I mean that's that's a
that's a significant amount of money
kids loved Hitler but it's a price we
should all be willing to well here you
go Olivia found it this sounds
you're uh 2022 budget act this is for
California
so it's uh 596 million it's about half a
billion and then half a billion and then
additional 150. our what's the 150 for
that's for other programs to increase uh
well I just had it up right now so it's
nine so it's 590 plus 150 so it's like
740 million hey that's a lot of money
California state budget I mean how much
does California take in in taxes
that is a good question how much does
California taken
taxes every year
they just play this in the cafeteria
[Music]
that's right a damn country
damn shame
um probably one percent of the LAPD
budget yeah maybe no La P what uh no
that's not true lap LAPD budget is like
a billion uh so it looks like uh in the
past fiscal year 2022 through 2023
um the general funds budget of
California was uh 22 billion
nice
what does California spend all of its
money on
all kinds of because like
other states don't even have the income
tax like and we
have all this money
what do we do with it all
you know we have a lot of Public
Services here in California compared to
a lot of other states just think about
all the complaints we hear about people
that move to Texas I just read an
article the other day about
it was funny because everybody was like
making fun of this person on Twitter but
I thought it actually was insightful
they were like a Silicon Valley person
who moved to Austin like so many people
from California are doing and he was
just talking about how terrible the
public services are there like you don't
even realize
um like well school system and uh
utilities cost a on there
internally and and they suck like in
Texas and they're bad right it's like
World Service people way more money just
turns off until it gets hot so that's
good to know you know what I mean like
hey it's we pay a price but I guess
stuff's good here you know and I like
that I like that
I like California I'm trying to leave
Tech spent you know save 10 on your
income tax so the kids can't you just
because kids want to eat lunch at school
psychotic
actually psychotic
I lived in California my whole life
if I'm gonna start making a bunch of
money and then bail to another state
just because I don't want to pay 10 to
support
the other people in my state I grew up
in it's
pathetic
in my opinion to leave for that
no loyalty man
love for State bruh
so I feel like once you're at the point
where you're making enough money
why do you care
It's never enough
right I'm gonna have to talk to people
who do that they go I could save you
know two million dollars by moving to
Texas a year
it's a lot of money but
ultimately when you die is that two
million dollars extra you're saving
gonna have any impact on your life if
you're making that much right that means
you're making 20 million a year
if you're saving that much
easy to say when you're rich well that's
my point
we are talking about rich people that
moved out because of the attacks yeah
that's kind of my point you know what I
mean anyway uh what is California's
state budget look like I am curious hold
that up for me
what are we spending our money on man
you know
uh okay well here's a summary chart uh
this is exciting and here's the general
fund because
I'll make it bigger
AP net Reserve Public Schools we have
900 that's it so there's only 900
reserve for Millions
it's the budget the state budget
um
by agency can I just get a pie chart
yeah I got I sent you a pie chart all
right you got a point chart yeah give me
a pie chart scroll down a little bit all
right let's take a look here total State
funds the biggest one here is Health and
Human Services well there you go
there you go dude higher education
that to me is hilarious that we're the
state is giving colleges money and it's
still so expensive like what all
right
yeah and the UC system is one of the
best college systems in the country too
right so well the UC system's supposed
to be like affordable for California
residents and it is significantly
cheaper for California residents right
but it's still really expensive they're
hard to get into too and they're hard to
get into yeah they don't you know what's
crazy they don't favor people from the
state so like
even if you live here it's so hard to
get in those schools
and then so you have 36 Health and Human
Services 26 percent
uh kindergarten to 12th grade education
eight percent higher education and you
can click on any of these for a
breakdown
Transportation uh business so I mean it
seems like we're doing it on pretty good
stuff here and you can you can click on
any of those pie chart
um categories for a specific breakdown
of where it goes
it sounds great
looks good to me right I didn't know you
could look up this gun yeah it looks
great yeah yeah I mean it's all I don't
know what I'm looking at mostly but yeah
it looks great wait what the
Environmental Protection is 1.7 can you
click that I feel like that should be
higher
um
let's put a little more money there
what's the police budget yeah where is
police well uh uh law enforcement for
the most part is a municipal thing yeah
um there are State Police but compared
to like LAPD it's very small
okay so I imagine that's in judicial and
executive
this kind of stuff what's that there's
anyways this has to be really really
fascinating for everybody that doesn't
live in California well I'm just it's a
peek into the state uh you know
bureaucracy put up a little bit up a
little bit tiny bit this is the biggest
one Secretary of State why are they
getting paid so much
what the Department of Jobs
probably not just to them personally or
maybe it is I don't know
all right thank you
just defend my state a little bit here
you know what I mean
now LA on the other hand's a different
story these got to get
their together because look at this
police
is the second
expenditure the top one is other special
purpose funds you can you be more yeah
please what you can if you click on it I
think it says
um
other there's no data
I click very good but yeah I mean this
is a huge problem in L.A the police
annual budget is two billion for 2023
maybe that's why there's no data
am I reading that right
uh yeah 2 billion
LA City spends 2 billion a year on
police that's bizarre dude but that's
like 10 of the entire state budget
spend a lot of money on Cops
it doesn't even make sense
yeah because they buy them like tanks
and
dude that's crazy
yeah that's a big problem here in this
in the city
thank you
we gotta well if only we just need one
money for the police yeah this city can
finally be safer politicians actually
run on that they go we got to clean up
this city by increasing the budget to
the police that's crazy like they
already have every all the money how can
you actually say those words
because it just sounds good I guess
we need to give them another billion
dollars so that they can have more tanks
more missile launchers more Apache
helicopters to rain Hell Fire on the
homeless
we still haven't talked about anything
all right let's move on let's do some
let's do some stuff now God there's so
much that we have to catch up on because
of the short week we had
actually I got to show you this
video it blew my mind I've never
seen anything like it this is in
Australia which is you know where you
expect to see stuff like this but even
still I had a hard time believing this
was real watch this what no yeah
no way yeah
they're freaky what is it doing up there
it's a giant snake going from
the rooftop to a tree and this looks
like the Anaconda scene
this is not real
how crazy is that
this can't be real it's real
only in Australia
oh my God terrifying what is it doing up
there that is like a straight
prehistoric Beast
so cool and scary at the same time
he's so strong yeah powerful
it's like magic
he's going yeah watch the tail falls off
it's so massive you're going to the next
tree the snake and tree trap what is a
snake doing on trees no for real this
looks like a magical creature in a
Disney movie look at that tail dude oh
my God she's just she's flying yeah
basically imagine this thing falling on
you hi you must be so heavy
what does that thing eat no there's a
kangaroo people
the Dango that eats the dangers so that
was that's pretty incredible right I
just want to watch that snake all day I
wouldn't mind that
would be friend drama that was so cool
but uh 23. all right all right
uh so cool
also this is kind of funny before we
move on I'm almost done
now is the time to invest in Phase stock
I know you all been looking for the
right time to enter yeah it is at the
lowest price it's ever been at 23 cents
down 96 now is the time I was saying if
I put like if I can put together a
million dollars I think I'd be a
majority owner of this company going to
the Moon baby we're gonna be making some
serious changes around here according to
plan daddy Ethan's about to come over
[Music]
oh that's crazy so good for them you
know it's always smart it's always a
good idea to go IPO
so it's smart
the shutout Phase Clan phase up raise up
face down
face down face down face up but face
down also all right so let's talk let's
do the PowerPoint first and then we'll
come back and do the uh
the the gay Obama story which is so good
gay Obama and then Logan and Dylan all
right so so you want to get started um
all right I've seen a lot of chatter
about this Joe Jonas I didn't know they
were getting I mean I knew they were
together and that they had a kid right I
knew that much but that was all that I
knew but then I just there he's then
they're getting divorced I mean it's sad
you know they just had a kid I mean geez
man let's let's let's work it out
um
but uh well when you get to that point
I'm assuming it's not workable anymore
yeah yeah probably not so here let me
open uh
let me open the PowerPoint
now how do we feel about the Jonas
Brothers uh because I don't know much
about them I'm I'm acquainted with
Frankie the young one he's a fan and we
love Frankie but I don't know much about
these Jonas boys
the Jonas Brothers we do we grew up
listening to and watching the Jonas
Brothers okay
they all have like super famous like
significant others too it seems like
they do yes Sophie Turner uh Priyanka
Chopra and Kevin's wife
she was on a reality show with him I
don't know her name though
there it is
so
I'm a sucker for divorce Goss is that
the name of this
all right I'm a sucker for divorce Goss
what the hell what happened
wait why did she look so different
that's bizarre yeah
is that her that's her yeah it looks
warped like her it looks pulled yeah I
think it's just this story so he looks
gone
before we begin
very quickly a rundown of what has gone
on this past week Joe Jonas filed for
divorce from his wife actress Sophie
Turner known for Game of Thrones
um it seems though that the media is
reporting clashing narratives so we want
to investigate that a little bit today
um the whole world is basically just
speculating and trying to guess what's
happening I mean I'll just stay right
off the bat
I do not have love for men who divorced
their newly birthed
significant others I mean that's
it's like you see it all the time these
successful guys they bail on their
significant other who's just sure well I
might get too dramatic but they've gone
through so much they've changed their
body to give them a beautiful gift of
children and then they bail for some new
ass
so shallow no we don't know that
specifically about him I think Ethan is
just saying angel in general is
something though that you see happen
agree yeah they just had a kid and he's
divorcing her I mean come on dude again
I don't know any of the details so let's
move on right
players Mr Joe Jonas of the Jonas
Brothers do we need any clarification
about where he comes from I don't think
so he's just they do music they had like
a boy band they're like the Bob kids
right yeah they split up for a second
they came back together
that's handsome yeah I thought I was
kidding but you you've coached him
better Hanson or
Jonas Bros yeah Jonas Bros Jonas love
bug is a good song
it's very very powerful Bob
all right very good okay Sophie Turner
Game of Thrones she is most known for
um she started in that show when she was
14.
oh my God I love the hair oh they have
two kids together all right who kids
damn
the most romantic meet cute location is
where our lovebirds met each other
um Joe slid into Sophie's DMS in 2016
and the two hit it off
um at the time Joe was 26-27 and Sophie
was like 19 20.
okay
little girl
um
then Joe swaps that 2010's purity ring
for a wedding band uh the Jonas brothers
were known for wearing Purity rings in
their teen years uh what they're like
they were like virgins yeah they ditched
them though
that's all ditch you know who else had a
purity ring like
not to be a fan
never mind everyone else who had sex
before marriage yeah exactly doesn't
mean much
um all right so after one year of dating
the two were engaged and then they got
married in Vegas in 2019 and then
afterwards they had a more formal
celebration
okay okay next baby one
next
maybe two okay next what's up okay
Photoshop
a little something I threw together last
night wait is it back is his face not
Photoshop oh I didn't do that one that
one I think TMZ posted that with their
first announcement am I tripping it's
just a weird picture well because it
just looks like pasted
yeah that's the work of teams
maybe maybe just the background they
pasted on there I can't tell it's just
very odd wait what are you talking about
you didn't make this Olivia I didn't
make the photo of them holding a child
clearly Photoshop look at his hairline
and the balloons are obviously oh we're
trying to see if it's if it's his face
photoshopped on that body it definitely
is or is it a photo that's what it looks
like bro but that background's
photoshopped as well so what the
did they do yeah right it's not even a
good Photoshop like look here but
between his ears and they didn't even
really try I thought Olivia did this in
like a minute
all right now I wish
there it is okay so now we've caught up
to present time okay um TMZ reported
earlier this week that Joe Jonas and
Sophie Turner were heading for divorce
now we're gonna get into each
bit of information that was released to
the public and we're gonna try to piece
together what we think is happening
because the rest of the world is doing
that as well okay fair so before we
begin hold on go to the next slide hold
on no everything is speculation keep it
in mind okay uh the next slide is only
is the only definitive information we
have from the horse's mouths themselves
so
a statement between the two was posted
to Instagram after four wonderful years
of marriage uh we have mutually decided
to amicably end our marriage there are
many speculative narratives as to why
but truly this is a United decision and
we sincerely hope that everyone can
respect our wishes for privacy uh for
privacy for us and our children oh
beautiful statement that's the end all
right I think that sounds beautiful the
PowerPoint wow I love to see it you know
it's nice when people can separate
amicably for this you know mature polite
yes all right I guess that it just says
the end next yeah that's fair oh oh all
right breaking it's then reported some
people I thought when I saw this for the
first time I was like that's a little
bit weird like why did they report that
like right after the divorce thing it
said amid their separation Joe Jonas has
reportedly been caring for his two
children with Sophie Turner pretty much
all of the time over the last three
months even while on tour it's just like
what do you mean that's a really loaded
line yeah amid their separation really
dragging her that's a plan as a mom well
something that is happening in Sophie's
life is she took she kind of cooled off
from working when they had their babies
and she is now back in England filming
for like the first time since so that's
that's what she's been doing in like the
past two weeks amid their separation Joe
Jonas has been caring for his two kids
Sophie turning Turner pretty much all of
the time quote over the last three
months
because Sophie posted this is really
rubbing me off so where'd they get that
information
it's all like Insider no he it was
leaked to the Press right right yes so
supposedly his words right the quote
part do you remember when um we were
talking about Ariana Grande we were
talking about like insiders it's that
these Outlets have a relationship with
someone who is close to the celebrity
sometimes I think that the celebrity
doesn't know or I don't know but it's
just like there is a link there and then
they each want to preserve those
relationships so like they don't
over each other
but so he put out the nice amicable
statement but then in the meantime
putting out this kind of correct
and I mean look three months that's how
marriage works dude I'm sorry to tell
you but you married an actress like you
know the deal yeah I mean you
know nobody would bat their eyes if it
was like
her saying I've been taking care of the
kids for three months right nobody would
even think that was a headline yeah take
care of your kids dummy that's what
you're supposed to do yeah yeah this is
very weird so after that came out then
another thing came out that said
she likes to party he likes to stay at
home they have very different lifestyles
brah who is saying this stuff like that
seems very
you couldn't have come with something
else that's a hit job that's a head job
for sure yeah
she likes the party
he likes to stay home
they have okay okay all right all right
how old is she and how old is he again
um so when they
had their baby she was 26 and he was I
have this written down
uh she was 26.
she's 27 now yeah and how old is he
yeah
34. oh
okay I mean
um
I get the feeling again I'm just
speculating but
she's probably like all right I'm gonna
go grab a drink with my friends
somehow I doubt she's out there probably
what the do I I don't know anything
well that's the thing that's it's all
speculation yeah it's all specular but
it's like their teams are releasing
these bits of infield it's so weird
that's a dirty and at this point it's
like two that are dragging her like why
are we doing this there was no need for
that no need for that yeah and then next
I think it is yeah so then this comes
out and it says that Joe and Sophie were
having problems when he became less than
supportive as she struggled post-birth
of their second child and then he
pressured her into attending events so
this is reporting that he likes to go
out this is so messy yeah they're
dragging each other yeah through TMZ
what the why you guys gotta do this
he started it I feel like he started it
based on what we're saying he definitely
started it but like this sucks why you
guys gotta be why is it got to be like
this you know what I mean I know like
y'all would have been fine
but I feel like for a woman to accuse
her of being a bad mom is like the worst
thing you can do and so I can understand
take it personally why she feels like
she needs to respond that's true it's a
direct response to that accusation and I
feel like when when a dad like I also
saw that article that you sent
you see that a lot and we've seen it too
when a dad does like the bare minimum he
gets praised like oh my God what a
perfect dad like we even when you just
change the diaper like your own mom was
telling me like he's such a great dad
yeah
it's pretty sad and it's like
it's like far is so low
well and it's cool because you are a
great dad when my mom but you know
you know because you change your diaper
people are like you're right and because
back when they were married the guy
didn't do anything it was normal for men
to be like I earned the money yeah and
you do the kids stuff I never change a
diaper
yeah moms are so insanely scrutinized
especially online
everybody has something to say uh okay
next
you know what I've noticed about these
photos together lots of a glaze
they're all pretty glazed up
you know what I mean yeah lots of
glazing and more money all right go on
take out that Mormon glaze okay sources
tell TMZ that Joe filed for divorce
after allegedly catching Sophie Turner
doing or saying something on a ring
camera what is this Joe had access to a
ring cam that's why I wrote no that
doesn't work either
uh Joe had access to a ring Cam that he
said captured so if he's saying and or
doing something that made him realize
the marriage was over what what are
these weird statements let's see
why is it so cryptic what we're saying
like either say something or don't
that's what I'm trying to say
I mean twist my arm it kind of pushes
you to be like oh is she having she did
something did you see her like cheating
on him or she did something she did this
she gave me no other choice I won't tell
you what she did right but she gave me
no other choice right
right
so a lot of people were saying that um
this feels very reminiscent of Britney
Spears
um when she and Justin Timberlake broke
up there was an insane smear campaign
against her I think if you saw the
Britney documentary you know about it
and then Britney's mothering abilities
her maternal abilities were super
scrutinized I was looking through a
bunch of different magazine covers this
is just one of them it's both of her
children plastered on it and it says
soda in baby bottles mommy's many men
nighttime cries for Daddy's left like
that's so that's so invasive intrusive
they don't know anything like it's just
a lot of people are saying that they
still reminiscent
yeah or would they
I feel like people will get angry if
someone did that today I think so too
with the kids face and yeah
which is good insane well there are
adults now those babies but yes today no
I know
um so I just wanted to include there is
a
um quote that a lot of people are
posting right now about something that
Sophie said in an L interview in 2022
she said I miss England so much the
people the attitude everything I'm
slowly trying to drag my husband back
so a lot of people are saying that um
it's possible that
she was not feeling like her needs were
being met fully
okay yeah
um
a lot of people were saying that because
she began filming Game of Thrones when
she was only 14 she never really had
time to experience being a young person
and going out
um
sounds like they married when she was
pretty young she did yeah yeah they were
dude she started Game of Thrones when
she was 14. yeah and now she's 27.
dude that's for me
yeah so then the next day
paparazzi photos come out of Joe with uh
their babies
TMZ snapped them a lot of people
speculate because it's TMZ specifically
a lot of people call Paparazzi on
themselves that's obviously a huge
speculation but if he did do that
that's just bottom of the barrel
but if he didn't then he didn't
at least they blurred the faces so you
can see there's like at least some
improvement in terms of how they agree
talk about the kids at least damn right
okay who knows you know yeah it's
possible that they got um
yeah
okay and then I just know that
I wanted to include because people in
the chat have been spamming it
um she
so there is a story that Gigi Hadid told
in an interview where she says that Joe
Jonas who was her boyfriend later in
life approached her when she was 13 and
he was 19. and she said that yeah here I
have I've had on video I have the quote
so she said she met Jonas a musician at
the Grammys when I was 13 years old and
that he asked me to go to a baseball
game and I said no I was so nervous I
literally didn't even know what it meant
to hang out with a boy Hadid said
according to the 2015 article also
Grammys are on a Sunday and I didn't
want to tell him I had school the next
day so I was like no maybe next time I
didn't have my phone with me and I don't
think he did either because we were at
the Grammys and so he wrote his number
on a piece of paper and gave it to my
mom she went on and then we've been
friends ever since except now we're more
than friends OBS so she wasn't even
trying to drag him no she was like
that article says like oh at the end
from like the author she sizes like so
wild what was the age difference 13 and
19. 13 and 19. that's so interesting to
me that like she thought that that
didn't sound horrible and then the
author thought that sounded romantic and
then the mom passed the number yeah
don't they have a notoriously weird mom
Yolanda yes yeah almond mom times ten
yeah wow that is super weird yeah and
then the story of Joe and Taylor is that
he broke up with her over the phone 18
second phone call
okay well whatever
can't judge him but these are just those
are stories and then next is just yo
he's is he like the cute one in the in
the group Joe is my fave
in terms of
you he's the most desirable he's the
cutest he's the cutest he was also the
lead in Camp Rock so he was my leading
man yeah yeah that's true I mean Taylor
Swift Gigi Hadid yep yeah you know he's
out well Nick was the one who got with
all like the Disney girls at the time he
dated Miley he dated Selena wow you got
it
there it is yep so thoughts that photo
by the way was posted by Sophie just
three weeks ago it's a glaze this one
yeah
it's just a glaze shot
I don't see glaze in this one this
doesn't look that glazed well if she's
kissing his hand that implies I don't
think she knew that the divorce was
coming right
no I don't think shinyu well they're
also in public in front of cameras you
know what I mean but like the kissing
the hand was an unnecessary gesture
oh there's just happened to be in front
of her face I think oh is that right so
then that's how I see it who knows then
who knows
what do you think Olivia I don't know I
am hesitant it's just a Fed picture you
know to be definitive about every
anything
um I thought she's kissing his hand but
if not then it really doesn't say much
yeah well she's definitely kissing his
hand it looks like either if she knew
about the divorce they were covering it
up or she was blindsided Maybe
I don't know why else you would post a
photo of you like kissing your husband
if you were getting
I agree divorce yeah I think it yeah it
implies if anything that she didn't she
didn't she didn't know yeah I agree
is that it well
yes that is that's all the info we have
that's it that's it
well wait people have been like dragging
Joe
and
[Music]
um
I feel like it's been going both ways I
think if anybody's dragging him it's
probably because it looks like he
started this and made it very messy yeah
the
um Court of public opinion right now is
calling out the smear campaign that
people think Joe is Joe's team is doing
against Sophie right now and
what do people criticizing Sophie for
what could she have done
well the the accusations of she's not a
good mother she's not neglecting she
likes to party like those are the things
that were released
that she yeah I don't know so
non-specific I mean no it doesn't really
say anything enough to I don't think
criticize somebody for but you know
people do
okay
that's what's happening
yes just very very messy
that's what's happening today
okay so that was shorter than I thought
so maybe we'll have time for everything
sorry
all right so should we do I guess uh
poll and see who's team who should we
gauge I know I know who's team what
I don't think Joe's gonna have much
support in our audience
it's hard to see where
he's not Joe the dick in this situation
Joe it's hard to see it go to Joe
but the facts as they are
Joe 2011.
he's the best isn't he folks
we're rooting for you Joe
everything do it you know what I mean
it's kind of hard to imagine
um that he's not the dick here
well 87 are teamed Joe Sophie yeah
right yeah that's pretty skewed because
the thing the thing that he put out is
like super non-specific it's like oh
there was rain footage she did something
on the ring she likes to party it's like
okay
what do you mean
all right
well
we wish you all the best don't we wish
them all the best yes wish them all go
to Joe Jonas 20 old
25.03 300 for Joe I'm gay
what
wow what was that Jill Biden Joe I'm gay
why did he say that
I think he was talking about a gay
marriage or something like that I'm gay
I think that was Obama's line I speak
English let's go to Obama then because
this is awesome
so are you do you know what this is I
only know from the title not
um I haven't seen anything about it can
you get me the uh trailer the teaser he
did because I see we have the full link
to the interview I'm not sure
so he interviewed this guy
interviewed this guy
and thank God Tucker is
he's unethered by the restraints of
journalistic the journalistic Integrity
of Fox News because now he can do really
hard hitting stories like this
the gay guy that had sex and smoked crap
with Obama love it
um here's that has to be true here's the
here's the trailer that dropped Tucker
posted this on Twitter and this one when
we all kind of lost our mind
I was in town for the night and it
sounds like you're looking to party yeah
pulled up in a bar outside and there's
this guy that's introduced to me is
Barack Obama I had given Barack 200.
literally he goes this man claims he had
it's like okay well me too come
interview me like do we have any
corroborating oh my God I don't need any
well we do we have a lot of evidence
about the story actually but not
not in the affirmative we have a lot of
evidence of why this story is oh I can
tell you right off the bat if Obama
wanted to dudes he could pull
so give me a really detailed account of
exactly how the sex played out
how I put my hands on his thighs and we
started to engage in all is that what he
looked like at the time yeah stop
no not at the time no I think this was
from I could be wrong I thought this was
from an article because this is an old
story this is it was in 99 this is uh oh
yeah I guess not at the time but the
first time that he came out publicly
about this so this was around the time
that Obama was running for president oh
I see so this was a headline on some
tabloid on the national
examiner yeah this is like bad boy stuff
isn't it yes what and so so Tucker said
I'm gonna go to the batboy magazine
years later and dig this up yeah like 10
years later not in the public eye pretty
much at all this is the level of
Journalism Tucker I didn't know that
this was an old story yeah it goes all
the way back to the campaign like 2008
oh my God Obama hid gay lifestyle to be
president marriage to Michelle is a sham
he had sex with this man
and that looks like a mug shot too wow I
believe it is because he has a long rap
sheet yeah this guy
I love that they inquire The Examiner
used the mug shot like you know they're
like we don't believe this either
but it's funny yeah Tucker's like I buy
it
I buy not only does he buy it he really
is like diving in tell me more digging
it up it went the direction I had
intended it to go even though you had
sex with him twice you did cocaine with
him watched him smoke crack twice you
had no idea who he was I had no idea who
he was and how big was his would
you was he a good lover
uh I do have some information about that
actually oh tell us Tucker didn't ask
him but somebody else did I found in a
what did he say well we'll get to it
we'll get through it okay
Obama's got a hog for sure it's a
shocking Revelation
the obvious question what was Obama like
on crack uh what was he like on crack
that's my favorite part those will
probably like on crap wait
I have that part timestamp where he
explains crazy this is so
unbelievably
embarrassing for Tucker Carlson like for
real like how like a sketch like a
comedy sketch how do you look at
yourself after this this is so pathetic
but like it has a 190 000 likes and 72
million views on Twitter I think even
talker's like you know what this is
completely wrong but it's entertaining
but he's basically the bad boy reporter
now
let's go
is it your sense that that's who Obama
is just transactional or that he's
bisexual or like what is this it
definitely wasn't barack's first time
and I would almost be willing to bet you
it wasn't as long the guy's running from
Clarity
just little old me the strobe the little
crackhead me
he's like
oh this is so good
incredible information comes out that
he's smoking crack and having sex with
dudes that's having sex with dudes well
it would be a story of the media really
cared about telling people the truth
and just to be clear I'm they're just in
search of the truth having sex with
dudes is not an issue that's not an
issue that I I just want the truth you
don't have an issue with the crack
either frankly
you had sex with Obama you smell crackly
yeah
wait he was there now dude you had
sexual Obama you smoke crack how many
times wait hold on I think it was twice
you let Obama hit I just said
[Music]
what was
incredible so so here's the full
interview the full one dropped okay I'll
be happy to report right now that at
least it didn't get that many views on
YouTube well that's a re-up yeah so
where's the main one on Twitter it's on
Twitter yeah let me see what this
got a few eyes although it's so inflated
on Twitter who knows yeah it doesn't
show views anymore on Twitter you can't
actually see all you see is Impressions
which means nothing
so it has 180 000 likes on Twitter
that's a lot it says 33 million views
but that's it's not views it's
Impressions Impressions and Impressions
is like in my experience it's got to be
like
a hundred times more than the views
maybe even more that could be like three
million anytime it just appears on your
timeline because somebody else retweeted
it or I guess that would be 10 times I
remember looking at um The Impressions
to views back when they were different
and I'm it's it's a huge huge difference
yeah but based on the amount of likes
it's a lot
sure I mean what's the average
click-through rate on YouTube because we
know that right
the average click-through rate I mean it
varies a bit but like let's say two to
five percent
probably right right so I would guess
it's something similar on Twitter you
could probably take two to five percent
probably even less on Twitter because
it's so transient so what's two percent
of 33 million five percent means
everything
uh what was the total 33 600 000 33
million 33 million two percent
six hundred thousand yeah rough six
hundred sixty thousand
so that makes sense to me yeah that's
not a lot of views yeah is who's paying
him for this dumb I think so fun I
I don't know if it's ever been confirmed
but I thought it was implied that
Twitter is paying this is why walking
dude this is such good content Elon
Twitter yeah elon's always retweeting
this too no
Tucker on X so yeah I think that oh it's
like with X it's got X in there oh my
God
so what should we do should I wow
certain parts I Should Skip too yeah I
had a couple time stamps that just
really hurt my brain right now here he's
talking about the gay crack accusations
this is uh the the good part you might
say so Twitter Twitter is co-signing
this they are and paying for it actually
even more than co-signing it
Elon Musk specifically I would say
one of the most interesting moments in
the 2008 campaign occurred when a man
like Obama himself came from out of
nowhere to recount his experiences with
Barack Obama the man his name was Larry
Sinclair Larry an amazing story he said
that in 1999 he had encountered Barack
Obama in Illinois had sex with Barack
Obama and then used cocaine with him
Sinclair went on to make these claims
publicly at the national Press Club in
Washington to sign a sworn affidavit and
to take a lie detector test but he was
dismissed okay
very important detail here that people
have pointed out uh and this this just
shows what a worm Tucker Carlson
is what he just said he signed a sword
and affidavit and he even took a lie
detector test that story is well known
he took a lie detector test and failed
it so at this point really yes I feel
like this Wades into defamation
territory right just the way that he
phrases that yeah like imply like oh he
took a lie detector test he must have
passed that yeah he failed the lie
detector wow because if I can get sued
for reading the headline of a variety
yeah then I would say that Tucker's got
some liability here yeah he failed let
me go back and hear him yeah when I hear
that again yeah
the national Press Club in Washington to
sign a sworn affidavit Anna take a lie
detail
but he was dismissed why was he
dismissed why was he dismissed oh
oh that is the best in February
2008 he was offered a hundred thousand
dollars to pass the polygraph test by a
website regarding his claims while he
took up the offer the website said the
results of the test showed that he
indicated deception well that's a nice
great check he went he went to the wrong
guy
I had sex with Obama and smoke crack
with him that's true he got paid a
hundred thousand no no if he could pass
oh if he could pass which that whole
setup is pretty silly yeah this guy says
and I hate liars this guy says it's true
and he is legit as it gets my friends
um Sinclair then accused an advisor of
Obama of rigging the test by bribing The
Examiner yeah yeah
so please God please somebody Sue Tucker
for this Obama just you gotta do it and
Twitter too you know I mean like they're
paying for this
maybe that again that hasn't been
confirmed but I thought it was like kind
of implied because it's just so slimy
he's exclusive to Twitter I always
emphasize that well I don't think
Tucker's working for free
that's why I think it's reasonable to
infer that he's being paid something oh
I mean this is just unreal the deception
the just it's just it's unreal man
what's he thinking with this
um here let's listen
in fact he was attacked Obama shows like
Ben Smith the Politico batted the claims
out without refuting them they're absurd
and the rest of the media followed suit
but the claims weren't absurd there's no
way Tucker believes what a word this
guy's saying no shot
we're not claiming they're true of
course but they were certainly credible
this was a I'm not saying they're true
but they were certainly sad a person
said it
firsthand I'm trying to find if he's
actually like Behavior by someone
sponsored by them but it looks like
um he's not from what I've seen that
Elon Musk
said Twitter did not sign an agreement
with Carlson for his new show so he's
just like presenting himself as part of
it I saw Elon say something about it too
I thought I know but maybe but yeah
it was vague so I mean look at looking
at that be right yeah I've been looking
yeah it's it's not clear I mean I saw
what ELO read as well
either or it's promoted heavily yeah
and he's using like the X logo and
everything too yeah so Tucker on x wait
what yeah yeah that's like what oh come
on that's that there's a business
dealing going on here yeah it seems like
next yeah
affidavit to that effect
so the question is whatever he signed a
sworn affidavit yeah it's like yo what
it's hilarious Sinclair what's his life
been like since that's an interesting
story it turns out Larry Sinclair is
still alive he lives in Mexico okay but
today he's in our studio and we're happy
is that weird thing to say yeah I don't
know why why would he why do we think
he's dead yeah what did Obama kill him
right is that the implication like oh
Obama didn't have him off
yeah I'm not sure thank you for inviting
me uh where did you meet Barack Obama uh
it was by accident I was in the Chicago
area in 99 for Lee Duke's graduation
from the Naval Academy who's leading oh
the Navy okay
um I had hired a limousine service I'm
starting up did you live in Chicago then
no no I was actually living in Colorado
I had flown in the night before okay so
um I had hired a limousine service had
made it the driver aware that if Lee
couldn't leave the base because once
they graduate some of them actually get
their assignments and they're shipping
out and they can't leave the base that I
was still interested in going out and
had asked the driver if he knew anybody
that was available that might want to
show me let me fast forward this guy's
boring
um
here's where the guest is introduced
Politico noting that his this guy who's
talking his criminal record spans nearly
three decades
they report that Sinclair has a
specialty in crimes involving deceit the
record includes forgery charges in two
states one of which Drew him a 16-year
jail sentence
when did he have sex time to have sex
with Obama
right after he got out of jail I guess
16 years in prison
in 1986 Sinclair was charged with check
fraud and credit card charges in
Colorado
he was uh he's also he wasn't a model
prisoner in prison he was just
disciplined nearly a hundred times for
slew of infractions from assault
intimidation and drug possession
Sinclair is known to have 13 aliases in
Colorado
including Lair viscara Avila and
Muhammad Gahanna
this guy picked an alias Mohammed
Gahanna ham
[Laughter]
so I know this guy's whole life is alive
but I believe every word he says about
Obama yeah the lie detector bro
story specifically it just sounds so
real he took a lie detector and signed a
sworn affidavit and he's never lied on
documents before I think you well and I
think you um
skip this line but he was also convicted
of theft and forging checks in Florida
separately from all the other charges in
Colorado so he has light on documents
yeah people say the news is full of
where is Elon
on Tuckers we're back
he said
on this platform unlike the one-way
Street of broadcast people are able to
interact critique and refute whatever is
said you know what the
media is that's literally
you're such a
Elon invented
conversations
oh yeah also I want to be clear that we
have not signed a deal of any kind
whatsoever Tucker is subject to the same
rules
definitive statement
rewards mean subscriptions and
advertising Revenue share which is a
function of how many people subscribe
and advertisers
okay
whatever which is just kind of desperate
on Tucker's side to Tucker on it looks
really pathetic
um anyway uh back to his rap sheet
he was uh in 2004 he was trying to get
it weren't dismissed in a sworn
affidavit claimed he was Termini
terminally ill wait no he no no this
can't be right he's he's trying to sworn
after this had sex with Obama and smoke
crack with them
he's 20 years ago
no that's why Tucker said he's still
alive because he is terminally ill oh
right oh maybe that's why he was
clarified
nobody would it's awesome
all right here they start talking about
the sexual encounter which is the good
part let's go what point
um so you start rubbing his leg and he's
I mean yeah let's get to the details
Kara at what point
um so you start rubbing his leg and he's
I mean I I think I'll just be totally
blunt with you he lost his words a man
who's not into gay sex would be like
whoa whoa sounds settled down trust me
if it was something that you were not
interested in yeah uh and you're right
I've had guys that I've read wrong that
would literally try to break your hand
for sure if you were for sure so it's
not like this was something that he said
it looks like his hands were broken
wait I just like that what happened last
night
some personal experience
wait also they have branded mugs Tucker
on X oh my God he's committed he's
committed there's no shot he's like
trust me people have bit the out of
me just last night
some people they broke up
shocked by you don't get excited and you
don't unbutton your pants and you don't
just sit there and let it happen yeah so
it wasn't it definitely wasn't barack's
first time that much I'm I'm absolutely
certain of
um and I would almost be willing to bet
you it wasn't as lost
like basically you could you could say
basically that his profession in one
word is deceit that's kind of sums up
his criminal uh history and here is
Tucker our dear dear friend
whose profession is the seat
right
birds of a feather it's just that he
just wants to get to the bottom of the
truth
thank God that we have these venues for
real yeah we can have conversations yeah
and uh somewhere where we can engage
because this is not one-sided
no it's a dick too
so um so you performed oral sex on I did
Obama how was that
um and how big was his load would you
say he almost got the point of option
not good give me more details what was
his balls
in in the drivers up front yep and he's
cool with us the driver has the
partition up he didn't have a problem he
didn't put it down for any reason I mean
he kind of set up the whole thing for
this in the first week exactly and I
have a funny feeling exactly no uh bones
to pick with it as far as what took
place yeah
I was super rich and everyone in
handsome and everyone loved me and I was
like my limo I had just cleared a force
cap for 50 G's I was feeling good
afterwards I actually went back to my
hotel I had specifically asked that he
dropped Barack off first but for some
reason he and Barack chose that they
would drop me off at the hotel first and
then he would take prop so I wanted to
try the limo driver too
[Music]
which is a suburb outside of Chicago
look at that God this is good yeah
he's really thinking hard
I'm so glad you concentrated good news
man for this it's really good
you know
he put on a suit for this he did I'm not
tired you know this really shows
because he had handlers at Fox and they
don't they would never let him run
too trashy for even them
it really shows how intentionally
dishonest like he is just a straight up
liar and like there's no better picture
of how bad faith he is than this yeah I
mean he brought on a Serial criminal who
lied who failed a lie detector test
that come tell his old story
this is a trashy tabloid story from
2008. the way that he mentioned the lie
detector but not the failing of it yeah
the Brazen took one I mean at least
ignore it don't even bring it up yeah so
brazen
so cynical
um to the hotel for me to be dropped off
what hotel was that it was the Comfort
Inn in Gurney oh that sounds depressing
it's like the most passionate he's been
so far
offered in you guys stayed there and how
much was the room it was about 19 a
night what
oh my god well I guess you guys had to
save money for crap I swear he's
trolling
rolling up to the Comfort Inn in a limo
like they do like we do over there
comforting bro they got the limos
rolling in all the time the Bellboy
helped us with our luggage
you have to remember it was 99.
and it was close to the Great Plain
Great Lakes Naval facilities yeah but
um
I got dropped off they left the next day
was somewhat interesting because he ends
up showing up at my hotel room
stalker weird
I love this this is weird you know I was
weird at the guy who just gave him a
and a limousine on the way home
casually
I was like he was weirding me out
but
he wanted some more yeah so when you say
he showed up he showed up I mean oh yeah
he had no warning Thursday in the room
there's a knock on the door there's more
he wants a relationship and was he naked
in some kind of Road perhaps and he's
standing there with more coke and he
comes in he's standing there
at the door with more coats a bag of
coke yeah let's go let's party like
Santa Claus and he was weirded out by
that that's party time boy
and it was just like a quick you know
rehash or rerun from the night before
exact same program exact same program
was he smoking again
so Barack Obama smoked crack and then
you perform sex on him and uh the only
reason I had come out in about it is I
had reached out to the campaign even in
2007.
only because I saw all these kids
getting excited about it okay wait it
was just so how did that end like same
way
smoking
you leave oh so during the presidential
campaign it also happened he's saying no
no no no no
no that's not what he said he said I
reached out to the campaign in 2000 okay
he was starting to Trail off onto
another part of the story I guess smoke
can crack a lot will uh
scramble your brains bye
and I'm talking about myself of course
right
what did you think of him
I thought it was interesting
I thought it was definitely a con
but what do you mean by that well in my
life at that point you would you you
made it clear I had already been around
yeah big time yeah big time
I've been around big time so you know
when people are
doing things because they actually
really enjoy it or they're sincere
they're looking you know for a
connection or they're doing something
because they're looking for an N or
they're looking for him or it's a game
yeah all right so for me
I felt that it was a game for him to get
what what out of you they do not follow
you're the dude that sucked them off in
the car ride onto the hotel what the
you
it was like okay what am I going to get
out of it or is there something I can
get out of it other than just because I
mean he brought crack that's a pretty
good and vice president for me yeah I
wasn't going back to Chicago anytime
soon so it really didn't matter so you
were left
with a bad taste in your mouth
dude this whole interview Tucker is
definitely visualizing him sucking awful
balls
he's got intro perfect in his brain he's
hard under the desk oh yeah no question
about it
with a bad taste in your mouth what did
it taste like wait what is it what he
tastes like you gotta tell me you gotta
tell me so you were left
with a bad taste in your mouth he did
not say that there's no way
what's his semen War viscous or watery
would you say
was it more of like a cream color or
more yellowish
could you could you please draw a
picture of his car
that would be helpful
there's something yeah
yeah
this man literally said the bad taste in
your mouth and nobody smiled
[Laughter]
um did you
talk to him again
I did not in fact I and did you have any
idea even though you had sex with him
twice and you did cocaine with him
watched him smoke crack twice you had no
idea who he was I had no idea who he was
until I'm sitting in my house and to
koala nagade Mexico in 2004 and I was on
the run from the law probably true
[Laughter]
that's a fair question yeah it should be
noted to he was a Senator at the time
too he's the Senator of Illinois right
so that's a pretty high profile wait in
1999 no he wasn't oh was he uh yeah I
don't I think this is pre-politics in
1999. okay no because later when he came
out about the story this was the crack
days yeah no he was a senator in from
97. this was Obama's crack Arc oh a a
state senator yeah right okay I'm sorry
yeah state senator in Illinois
I left a bad taste in my mouth he walked
on that stage in Boston and the DNC
convention and I literally hit the floor
I just hit the floor and was wait so
you're watching the Democratic
Convention from Mexico
smoke crack in Europe This is beautiful
I was laughing so hard oh he's so
beautiful absolutely positive
wow I don't forget people I've met I
don't forget people I have spent time
with sure that's a great quality that
adds up and just to just to restate
because I think you affirmed this but um
he used his real name yes
Rock
and so did the driver
so he said I'm Barack so because Barry
is his name
by the way uh Vince Staples had the
funniest sweet did you see it about
planting cracked I did see that actually
no about Tucker he said I hope Barry
drones this oh yeah I just saw that one
too sure there was another one because
that was what Obama was known for as
drowning people oh my God it's so funny
I don't bury drones this did oh it's the
best
funny
very funny you got another one for me
Dan oh there was just another one where
uh
[Applause]
yeah right here
I mean y'all focus on the wrong thing he
tried to put the crack rock on Obama
That's top tier smut
like police planting crack on people
when they're arresting them
gotta have them ribs gotta have them
dick dick too
and that's why at first when everybody
was referring to him as Barry I just
didn't understand or or catch on because
like I said I didn't know that much
about him
you know how dumb this is you know he
totally knows you know dude he's like
why are you doing this with your life
man that's so embarrassing like just you
know does he have kids I mean does he
have something to do
other than this
maybe he just doesn't have anything
going and this is just
he just wants attention probably he's he
probably is very starved for attention
because he was the biggest guy in news
and now he's just a total nobody
yeah
this is exclusive do you understand
literally anybody could get this guy on
the show probably yeah
nobody thought to ask that's the genius
we all thought he was dead yeah
you know you you hook up
Tucker has four kids go go brother
you know God bless him man
not this
it's grinder back then it was you know
the limo driver limos hey limo driver or
a bartender no shot right 80s just would
find limos to hook up in right yeah
how do you just find limos and find
dudes to have sex within them yeah I
don't even app for now I know also like
no you don't get to know who's in it you
just go for it
you know you know you ask and somebody
knows somebody or somebody doesn't he's
he's cannot believe what he's hearing
all right so let's see what else we got
here
um
at this point Tucker's we got that
starts talking about crack and how Obama
has done it before we got that
let's see when he failed a lie detector
he's been public with the story and two
since the 2000 when he failed a lie
detector test
he was all over the tablet he even did a
press conference at the time here he is
you know shot here is Larry at a press
conference in 2008. where he comments on
Barack Obama's penis size
what made Tucker think like let's do
this again
let's bring this guy back
oh that's him yeah doing a press
conference he kind of looks like cap
yes I'll hear if here now I know if
cavcv wasn't a nepo baby this is where
he'd be
now I know now I know the answer
be well hung actually I've always I've
referred to that you know what I'm going
to answer the question the same way I
always have
Barack Obama is a wannabe black man with
the white boys and that's where I leave
it oh why God
[Laughter]
I cannot be here
I love that this guy's gay keeping
Blackness yeah God he's a wannabe black
dude take it from me Larry Sinclair
yeah what uh here is he ran for mayor of
a town in Florida a few years back yeah
God that was one of those like weirdo
crackhead candidates that gay man who
said he had sex with Obama is running
for America
honestly it's probably refreshing for
him to be taken seriously for the first
time in his life
by this big by the biggest newsman in
America
uh Larry see it they actually they get
better context here Larry Sinclair a
convicted felon
who has claimed he had gay sex with
President Barack Obama is running to be
mayor Larry gave a speech at the
national Press Club in 2008 while Obama
was running for president alleging that
the then Senator Obama brought and
smoked cocaine and had gay sex with him
shame Sinclair who has served prison
time in Arizona Florida and Colorado
yo that's a hat trick how many people
can say they serve prison in three
different states all right let's go for
forgery fraud and larceny is now
campaigning to win the mayor's seat and
cocoa a town of around 19 000.
did he win
he did not
damn you did not
uh this is the real Catch Me If You Can
you know there he is all right that's
where I got the photo
[Laughter]
dude talking
out of pocket for this this is
so it looks like the Milady meme yeah
yeah for sure Obama
this is so sad when he was leaving alone
it's just so so so insane
um
so that's I guess that's the story yeah
that's it I mean there's the videos
about 45 minutes long after a while they
just get into a circle jerk about how
shitty he circled you the president is I
got the good stuff yeah I don't know you
get that you get the juice dick too
what what
are you Elon said of course the
probability his claims are true would it
rest on objective evidence rather than
claims made by someone with a dubious
history
huh
yeah I also saw this one Dave Portnoy
was uh had an interesting answer yeah
because port and I went on Tucker's show
a couple weeks ago and I guess they feel
like they Mass film I think they filmed
it on the same day really so Dave says
he met this guy said I met Larry
Sinclair when I was doing my Tucker
thing a couple weeks ago I would trust
anadel delvey before I trusted anything
Larry Sinclair said I'm assuming that's
the the lady who wrote the article about
him no no no Anna delvis she's the one
who like
um defrauded her friends oh okay okay I
know her I know a famous con woman yeah
so let's see I would trust her before I
trusted anything Larry had to say top to
bottom maybe the least trustworthy human
I've ever laid eyes on I'd say this
story has zero percent chance of being
true and that's generous
real she's real Dave but that's coming
what were you what are you doing
how can he do this there has to be
consequences so I feel like zero people
are buying this no Sarah's buying this
yeah but it's getting so much like
retweeting and stuff
you all The Usual Suspects I'm sure are
buying it but like not even like
I I haven't seen but I have to imagine
uh Ben Shapiro like people like that are
like this is stupid you know what I mean
look it up like maybe
Crowder maybe Crowder would take the
bait on this I'd say I'd say even
skeptical that Crowder would buy this
that's like I think there are old people
that could potentially be like oh Tucker
said it must be true Maybe
and I'm checking Shapiro right now let's
see yeah I want to know if anyone
covered it no Temple
Tim drool Tim pool seems like the type
of dude that would buy into this
uh here is this guy he has a video
called this guy claims he had sex with
Obama is he credible
oh this is Shapiro yeah that's what I'm
saying all right I'm not surprised you
commented I'm just saying I I have a
feeling with Barack Obama back in Barack
Obama's State House days in Illinois
now that's not uncredible
it isn't Barack Obama in his own Memoirs
talks about how he did a little whoa so
clearly the guy's familiar with drugs
Barack Obama wrote to it
that he regularly like every day had
fantasies about having sex with men
okay that is not conjecture that Barack
Obama wrote in his own hand to a
girlfriend which by the way is a weird
thing to say to your girlfriend in any
case okay
it's not a non-credible story okay so
the media at the time went after Larry
Sinclair they pointed out that he had a
history back in the 1980s so far and
then I just ignored the story now let me
point out that if Barack Obama had been
a republican candidate for office
this would have been front page story
all the time
he he is pathetic this man is defending
I'm sure he probably goes on to say
Larry but but he's already doing too
much Imaging it yeah he's hedging it big
time
dick too what dude come on man
wow
Ben Shapiro huh
Larry Sinclair
we should get him to call in yo let's
reach out to Larry
you want to talk to Larry I have some
questions for my boy and I'm sure you
come on if we offer to pay him I was
like yeah I'll give you 100 bucks if you
call in reach out to Larry yup yup this
is my dream I need to talk to Larry if
you give him 100 bucks more he'll accuse
Tucker of the same thing yeah if I give
you 200 will you say the exact opposite
yeah I need him to know I believe him
I gotta talk to my boy Larry he'll be
like oh yeah we cry we smoke crack in
the studio then had some sex he was
giving me a hand job
with his feet during the interview it
was super weird
dude I could have so much fun talking to
Larry yeah it
Good Friday by Toby in a political
disagreement this week that Obama is gay
crackhead who killed his personal chef
and brought up Michelle
nice okay Obama wrote him out that he
was attracted to men because he was
trying to impress bi girls when he was
in college yeah that was my I don't
remember the story well enough but I I
did remember having that thought that
yeah it seems he was 21 he was in
college and he wrote it to an
ex-girlfriend and he said something
along the lines of I make love to men
daily but in imagination
therefore vis-a-vis
Larry's telling the truth
it's all right there
the dots connect
all right what else we got
um
what was the other one in the headline
the other headline is Logan
all right great let's do that these are
all good stories
man it's gonna be a while since we see
another story like that
that's really just okay scoop of a
lifetime
so good
please we need Larry I need him yeah
don't you worry
it's important to me it's a paid gig
whatever he needs absolutely
um
sorry I'm chewing a little bit here
you don't say
so Logan Paul versus Dylan Dennis so
they're fighting
okay
and here I am talking about it so I
guess to an extent they got you
it's a KSI
fighting someone and Logan Paul fighting
someone
okay
and so Dylan danis is he an xmma players
that are a fighter that's what it is
yeah
and are they doing an MMA fight or
boxing it's just boxing boxing stupid
uh so he's fighting Dylan
the card it's of course uh sponsored by
steak
kick and Prime
a steak is just there
they have so much money they're just
like yeah we don't care we'll sponsor
anything
we have uh 50 million less right they
didn't even notice they even care they
correctly even didn't care about it at
all right somebody hacked steak and
stole 40 million and apparently it was
North Korea
really
oh
and now Sushi gang one of the owners was
talking to Aiden on stream and telling
him he needs to go to South North Korea
and interview Kim Jong-un
just sent it
which makes me very uh
so I know it sounds like when I heard
this the first time I didn't know the
context that they were just hacked by
North Korea is this if they have demands
for them because no I think I don't
think they're serious here he sounds
okay
I know it sounds like I'm kind of like
low-key around but I swear to
God like
going to North Korea and like live
streaming it and like giving them the
chance to kind of show their world off
and let's give them a chance to hear
their side of the story
that would be incredible content and I
would love to see Aiden wind up in a
labor camp like that that'd be such a
happy ending there's not there's not a
non-zero chance that he goes to hard
labor camp right yeah
like there was a story recently of some
kid that like stole a
bathroom towel or something and they put
them in hard labor and then delivered
his like rotting bloated corpse back to
America swear to God yeah I think they
remember it was a it was a while ago now
right it was not that long ago but
but if something tells me he's not going
to be in the countryside interviewing
peasants
Kim Jong-un no they'll play fortnite
together or something
if they return the money I think I think
this could happen let's give it a crack
like haven't think about it no pressure
I know you'll do it all right I got you
bro I won't let you down
I won't let you down you know what I
decided that you know what maybe I was
born
what the hell Twitter's
literally video players
Kim Jong-un
um I'm with Eddie man you know what I'm
saying I would love to come to North
Korea I would love to step in foot of
your uh your your country
um uh Mr Kim Jong I'd love to interview
you okay let me know uh we can do that I
got you ready yeah that would be great I
think that would be a really important
journalistic moment for Aidan Ross to
interview Kim Jong-un yeah
maybe maybe uh Dennis Rodman will be
there
that would be cool
so anyway unrelated but moving on
so
the uh talking started to me
immediately okay and by all accounts
this dude Dylan danis seems like a real
psycho
that being said
it couldn't happen to a worse guy
uh so here is their first press
conference
and uh Dylan goes immediately for the uh
he goes in my opinion the right stuff
and this is the stuff you should be
saying to Logan Paul you know one of you
friends with Conor McGregor where is he
by the way where's coach McGregor and
why would he take more he'll be here
take my million dollar bet I'm glad his
necklace says Prime I'm working on he
said why won't you pay back the people
from cryptozo okay I remember this clue
yeah it was good actually this one's too
short because he starts fumbling trying
to explain yeah it's like I'm working on
it bro I'm working on it and thank you
so you have watched this one we watched
this already
bet you're working on it I'm working on
it while he's wearing a blinged out
Prime necklace it should also be noted
though that Dylan Dennis has been called
out by coffee Zillow for scamming his
fans too is that right oh
beautiful
Dylan oh actually there's a community
note about it which is pretty funny
um
for what I said bro uh you guarantee a
win I'll bet you a million dollars I
beat dildo danis really that's the best
you got on October 14th uh Dylan said
bro has the money to bet one million but
can't pay off the people he scammed
that's crazy and then the the
community notes as Dylan Dennis has also
scanned his own audience on several
occasions and was exposed by coffee
Zilla the same person who suppose Logan
Paul that's so funny
well I'll say this about great people I
don't think Dylan danis is
putting himself forward as a good guy
whatever that makes a difference because
Logan's he wants to be like the good guy
he wants to be the Maverick
I don't know I don't think it matters
either way let me tell you about banana
I'm just trying to support Dylan for no
reason because I hate Logan uh here's a
link to the video coffee made on Dylan
all right let's take a look let's take
scammers he writes in a tweet damn Logan
Paul is a scumbag feel bad for everyone
he scammed now of course No One's Gonna
really disagree with this so the likes
rolled in but what Dylan doesn't tell
you is he also has a history of scamming
people on Twitter and what Dylan didn't
know is that there was a detective
watching him that detective was not me
actually I wish it was me it was my
buddy Zach xbt on Twitter who said damn
Dylan danis is a scumbag feel bad for
everyone he's scammed and then Zach
showed some tweets of Dylan promoting
obvious scams which then rug pulled now
I was gonna kind of leave that that to
me looked like this typical influencer
where they're like I'll pay you
twenty thousand dollars to link this
obvious scam yeah and a lot of people
did that a lot of people did that I
don't know that he was on the inside
which in my opinion is a lot different
level development involvement yeah being
on the inside is a lot worse than just
taking some some deal to post like and
by the way this link is like
really dumb feel bad for everyone he's
scammed and then Zach showed check out
squid game 2.0 and it's a
um
obvious scams which then rug pulled now
I was gonna kind of leave it there a
little knife
it got me thinking you know deleted scam
tweets are the internet equivalent of
roaches in your house in both cases if
you see more than all right whatever he
he also did it I mean yeah
um
here is Marvel though for sure here's
Dylan uh wearing the same Hat Logan wore
in the suicide forest which I think is
pretty great he started wearing it the
press conferences that's pretty which is
pretty good I think you know
it's really not a bad idea
it's pretty funny
yeah uh Dylan has been posting every so
this is where it gets a little dicey he
started posting every picture you can
find of his fiancee
with other men from before they met
that's so stupid in an attempt to
emasculate him I don't like that so this
is and he's really really really
harassing her uh he's done it over a
hundred times apparently
um here's a gallery
I guess she's she's dated a lot of
famous men and good for her you know
what I mean I'm sorry it's uh we wrote
this up a while ago it's 250 times now
holy
to 150 times he brought yeah he posted
about her it's so that's like a
full-time job man it's disgusting and
whenever someone tries to defend her I
believe Karina and tried to defend her
and then he does the same thing to
Karina yeah like bringing up her past
and showing stuff
um so he obviously is a nasty womanizing
freak and it's really up
but I feel like to the people that he's
um you know reaching out to it works
right like look at the engagement 90 000
likes what yeah he's so amazing people
are all about this 600 or 60 000
I mean it's like yeah dude she good for
her I mean what the let's see a
picture of everyone you've ever dated
you know or had sex with or spent a day
with yeah did she do anything illegal
I don't know Nick Cannon so what so she
dated people but now it's just pictures
with them like I you know it's all
it's it's just random I mean the
picture with that guy yeah
I mean the implication of course but the
harassment going on here is nuts man
yeah
it got really bad and this is not cool
at all to the point of allegedly sharing
uh Revenge
oh he did that well that's illegal yeah
that's all right yeah
um so
[Music]
probably it's on the internet yeah
uh
that's so gross
there's a video of a bunch of he posted
I mean like going after Logan was fine
why go after her and he has enough
things like the dead pet Sting the
scamming the suicide Force but he's just
come back he's just like a real dirty
dude and and like it's crazy that
it's working so well because like people
are spending rumors now that Logan's
divorce because
women that's why
yeah no I mean seriously that's why oh
she's a hell yeah yeah how many
people have you had sex with bro he also
allegedly shared a video of a random
girl I believe he was performing oral
sex that he claimed was Logan's ex and
it wasn't even her
yeah nice got him
so he died
yeah so it's like a mega compilation I
don't know
I was reading something that he has like
mob ties or I don't know if that's true
or not
I think someone's dying over there
it's just a Photoshop it's not even real
bro all right whatever stupid this is
really dumb so there that is uh that's
what he's been up to so now
um his fiancee
is seeking damages attorneys fees and a
restraining order against danis
this
is crazy
yeah yeah
This legal action follows weeks of
Dennis making numerous crude posts about
her implying a sex relationship through
photoshopped images she might have a
case that's the crazy part because like
150 200 times yeah
according to the lawsuit
what happened a race that line just
erased
what happened somebody just erased the
line here
Ctrl Z
uh I don't know according to the lawsuit
for the past five weeks Dennis has
posted daily
on his Twitter and Instagram
about uh his girl his fiancee
I can't say her name agadel
some of these posts include private
content
suggesting potential hacking or
unauthorized access the all right
yeah it's believe people are saying that
he hacked dude that's crazy that's like
straight up like this guy's insane
that's that's really intense bro
that's really intense so I feel like at
this point
Logan should
cancel cancel the fight but he's not
right he loves it he doesn't care I
think he if he cared about his fiance
yeah right I think that's a that's a
fair consideration that's the thing that
I would expect to prove that it's not a
setup too because I think you would do
that like you would be like this is
insane I'm calling the whole thing I'm
not trying to do anything with you why
I'm just saying like why why now her
life needs to be destroyed
she isn't she didn't sign up for the
fight
so for Logan to continue with the fight
it's kind of crazy what do you guys
think I I would I would too because I
don't want people to I don't want to
profit from this guy you know what I
mean but he doesn't and they had a press
conference recently can you pull up that
video by the way
uh it happened yesterday I think I saw
it on Twitter
that's a good point what do you guys
think should Logan cancel the fight if
he's really
I mean for safety it's his wife right
yeah just like if she has a restraining
order against them yeah is it worth the
fight like I know that some people are
saying that he Dylan is doing this
because he knows that Logan will beat
him or whatever so he wants Logan to
cancel but even if that is the case no I
mean like being safe is way more
important than being comfortable like I
don't think I don't think that's what's
happening
but actually I mean this fight is
getting insane coverage and I I honestly
think Logan loves it
that would make me really mad I think
if my boyfriend loved it or if my
husband loves exactly well I don't think
he's I think he
if he thrived off the attention of me
being miserable so here is um
meeting I guess this happened this was
posted by Logan eight hours ago
I guess I should put it on the screen so
you guys should see it
all right let's see this let's see if I
can play the unpause game here
this guy's like crossing the line of
like banter before a fight oh big time
Big Time he went way way way too low to
me the only conclusion here is to call
off the fight
well let's see here they they met just
yesterday
knee surgery it sounds like you have
Conor McGregor's nut sack in your mouth
well this guy has retweeted watches
that's what I'm saying right there like
watching you stumble your way through
these senses is is fun I agree I think
you just want to
hey what's happening you can't talk I
got better more what's happening
you send me so many messages why am I
well wait so there's a different clip
though
this is obviously one that's very I
don't know what that was it's probably
edited that was Logan yeah it might have
been edited
um I don't know what that was but he's
promoting the fight that's what he's
doing yeah promote it and him and his
brother they that's they thrive on that
they promote this they but you know
that's what they do so I do think in a
sense he is kind of throwing his fiancee
uh under the bus a little bit here eh
but I guess she chose Logan so
you know there's that that plays into it
a little bit she knows what she's
signing up for you I mean I guess the
hopeful thinking would be not not into
like harassed what I mean is to Logan
wouldn't cancel a fight for her I don't
think right
I guess the hopeful thinking would be
that they're having a conversation about
it maybe she's like it's fine for that
right true that would be okay
maybe although she it sounds like she's
going as far as to Sue this guy right
that's the other part if she's getting a
restraining order that means she can't
even be there during the fight right she
can't be in the same building that's
true yeah
that yeah if that tells me she's not
really down with this yeah
that's true
can you find the other one there was one
that made Logan look kind of scared and
weird
that I saw on Twitter
um here's Jake also dude Prime is but
babe Prime is sponsoring this
uh event my thoughts on Logan Paul and
Dan Dylan danis beef says Jake everyone
wants to know my thoughts on the Logan
Paul versus Dylan Dennis situation
and my thoughts are
that y'all should download better and
play better picks for NFL week one we're
giving away a Rolex right now to someone
who downloads better and plays better
picks for NFL week one create a slip all
the details these guys really don't give
a wow anything but making money
Logan Paul versus Dylan Dennis are I
mean let's like they really don't care
about anything about making money
remember he did that one sponsor where
you could win a hundred million dollar
house yeah the crate giveaway the loot
box the loot box yeah
so they just don't care they've
both and Logan Paul's a prolific scammer
too
I mean prolific really I can say that
were you able to find the clip I was
talking about
um
no I'm looking oh can you find that
whole press conference like what the
was that
that was pretty weird
uh furthermore
this action is said to be in violation
of the 20 if you show 22 violence
against women act reauthorized
reauthorization and New Jersey invasion
of Privacy Law Dennis has claimed that
his posts Were Meant to promote an
upcoming fight but has faced backlash
for the content and its impact on Agdal
Nina has been granted a temporary
restraining order so she got something
yeah this that was uh yesterday
as of Thursday Dennis 30 is forbidden
from posting content in any way
depicting or portraying plaintiff that
defendant knows or has reason to believe
was never meant to be shared okay so the
court just says you can't
Sharon you can't no more revenge porn
you had no more revenge for him please
um
yeah I'm looking for the clip too and
all I'm seeing is that clip of him
stuttering it's just like spammed all
over Twitter so is can you find the full
uh
conference
because I peek at that
kind of curious
here it is
I mean even this is unbelievable two
minutes unbelievable it's already begun
God damn it
the clip I saw is when they first meet
up when Logan walks in and they see each
other for the first time
let's see it's from two weeks ago
the hell yeah I'm sitting here in the
face to face waiting for Dylan Donuts to
show up Dylan Donuts there's nowhere to
be seen he has lodged himself in his
room
he has lodged himself in his room
Dylan have the panic attack started have
you realized what you signed up for
because this is real life bro no more
the prime the prime hackery is just
unreal with these guys like you will not
catch them on screen without a prime in
the shot it's pretty wild keyboard
Warrior Twitter I mean they're so
consistent with this it's kind of
impressive
he's in the hotel
and he's not showing up look look he's
supposed to be right there
for this it's not worth it yeah
right why not
probably not all right so that's that I
mean it's interesting something when is
this fight scheduled to happen
I believe it's October oh it's still a
ways out huh October got more a lot more
of this they gotta Pace themselves man
yeah
we're all gonna be burned out by then
yeah 14th of October jeez dude
yeah I'm not gonna remember any of this
all right
there it is there it is that's pretty
much it we've said it all people wow
we've said it all we've done it all Give
It Up
is my favorite coin like there's so much
more he could do than the girlfriend
thing but sadly that's hitting harder
than anything he's done which really
says a lot about Society it's sad I said
that that's the one thing that's like oh
slam dunk his girlfriend is a slot let's
go actually here is Paige is about to
break the unit another interesting
detail about him that kind of makes this
all make sense about Dylan he retweeted
a
Andrew Tate fan cam
Andrew Tate X Dylan they're collabing
again he announced his latest Meetup
that will destroy Logan Paul
Tate meets Dylan dance
oh my God
wait so where's the part where they meet
it's I think it's just an edited video
like a uh
a trailer for them to meet that's that's
weird Andrew hey you you Tate
heads are the weirdest sponge man yeah
the gayest bunch I have I want to say
that they're just obsessed with this man
he's shirtless all the time he's flexing
they're obsessed with his body they have
a crush on him yes yeah
fan cam yeah
there it is and there it is we've said
it all folks and that's Friday
that's Friday baby
so uh we're gonna reach out to Larry
Larry we're gonna make that happen is he
gonna come here in alimo
yeah make sure he does let's get it
we'll get him a limo you gotta talk to
him in a limo oh that's pretty funny if
you want a dude to suck you off that'll
be that's not included Larry right brain
Coke let's have him come here is Jimmy
Jimmy is probably gonna have a limo so
let me save some money there put him in
the same limo
interviewing Larry with Jimmy as your
co-host wait that's iconic it would be
good I'm Larry and c-man to me
hilarious
those two cameras they'd be like wait I
know you
oh my God we met at the convention
you're the driver that day the bath
house
so uh thanks for being here guys
welcome
thank you Dad for being here you got it
thank you um we'll be back next week
for another week of
good times here in the 8th Street
podcast you know how we do it we might
be having our tickets on sale next week
really right
is that hopeful it's probably well
it's possible that it could be as soon
as next week yeah okay we're waiting for
the final detail there's been a lot of
back and forth with the venue but it's
getting nailed down and we're getting
close but it's exciting like
I guess I shouldn't hype it yet because
it's not finalized yeah I'm not going to
say the name but the venue is absolutely
if we get the venue we're trying for it
will be next level next next
it's just a matter frankly it's just a
matter of price like if it's really
expensive and then it makes because this
is a very expensive venue yeah all right
then if it makes the ticket super
expensive it's not worth it I don't want
to right I don't want you guys to have
to pay a ton of money to come see the
show
like so that's that's the limiting
factor yeah so we'll see
but anyway it's like a Christmas
timeline yeah yeah it would be it would
probably be the finale like we did last
year
do Craigslist again potentially all that
good stuff all right y'all I haven't
paid this whole time on I've been yeah I
don't know how I did twice thank you all
so it's funny in the middle of the night
I gotta get up and pee all the time but
during the show I can
[Music]
soldiers
have a great weekend guys love you all
so much thank you to our members thank
you to our Saudi benefactor who
generously 500 today
go ahead Zach good luck to all the
pregnant women 500.
thank you all for watching and for being
here it means so much and I I love it
and I love y'all
have a great weekend look forward to
seeing you guys next weekend next week
on Monday
Tata
[Music]